Я хотів би наголосити на
важливості продовження інтеграції України до
європейського наукового простору,
адаптації європейських стандартів і норм
у процесі формування політики
наукового
та інноваційного розвитку, а також
подальшого розширення співпраці
з вами країнами-членами. Я хотів би
подякувати європейським колегам  оскільки
технічна та
експертна підтримка, яка надається під час підготовки,
є
іноземною,
я вважаю, що в контексті
майбутньої рамкової
рамкової програми для досліджень та
інновацій Horizon
Europe дуже важливо оцінити
результати спільних заходів, здійснених
у рамках рамкової програми Horizon 2020
, а також  вузькі місця такої
співпраці, щоб визначити
необхідні дії для покращення,
сьогодні ми матимемо можливість
почути розповіді з перших вуст про
можливості, які
надає участь у
рамкових програмах Європейського Союзу,
таких як Horizon 2020, і поставити свої
запитання нашим спікерам та
учасник
ми ще маємо багато потенціалу для
перегляду, враховуючи
глибоку співпрацю,
налагоджену за останні кілька років,
для України
важливо прискорити та зміцнити таку
професійну залучення
та взаємодію в майбутньому,
а широкий спектр тем сьогодні
надасть нам унікальні можливості для
обмінюватися ідеями
та робити внесок у політичний діалог
повільніше,
я запрошую вас розпочати зараз, і на цій
ноті я хотів би передати слово
генеральному директору директорату з
науки та інновацій
міс Джулія Базверссон, шановні колеги,
тому це я, а зараз ми почнемо з
Презентація про
впровадження psf
uh української та aaron dye system
so uh okay in, як відомо, у 2016
році Міністерство освіти і
науки України у співпраці з Європейською
комісією та консорціумом psf
має дослідження науково-
інноваційних розробок
ukraine дівчина метою даного опитування було
провести розгорнутий аналіз т.н  Українська
повітряна антисистема
, щоб надихнути український уряд
та політиків
на розробку та впровадження комплексних
реформ у сфері аеронавтики України,
процес зібрав низку
зацікавлених сторін, у
тому числі центральні органи виконавчої влади
Національна академія наук України,
вищі навчальні
заклади бізнес сектор громадянський
суспільство
багато українських вчених
взяли участь у цих дискусіях і
надали свою експертизу, в результаті чого ми
отримали детальний документ, який містить
певні основні рекомендації щодо того, як
переорієнтувати національну систему аеронавтики
та запустити її найбільш
ефективний шлях,
тож за ці роки
реформа аеродинаміки тут була в
процесі,
і багато з цих рекомендацій були
реалізовані, а
деякі з них зараз розглядаються,
і
ми сподіваємося, що протягом наступних років ми
зможемо зробити якомога більше в рамках цієї
програми
та пізніше  Я також скажу, що ми
в дорозі
о  f обговорюємо наступний psf щодо більш
конкретного сектора,
тому уряд продовжує
виконувати рекомендації під час експертної
оцінки.
О, деякі з них я згадаю зараз,
тож перша
була про координацію
фірми,
що розробляє політику в раю,
тут національна  було створено раду з науково-
технічного розвитку,
і зараз це серйозна
інституція, яка діє як дорадчий орган
та бере активну участь в інформуванні
про систему України
uh науковий комітет уг
ради складається
з 24 uh українських дослідників, які
наполегливо працюють протягом  У ці роки
надавали різні політичні документи та
рекомендації для уряду та
міністерства
в рамках реформи сектору aaron dye,
також минулого року було створено низку
тематичних груп,
які надали свої рекомендації щодо
різного
законодавства про батьківську
сферу, а
також ми  Очікуйте
наступного Національної ради з науки  науковий і
технологічний розвиток буде
мати зустріч у грудні цього
року
це дуже важливо для всіх нас також
ми створені в міністерстві
освіти це та науки
та окремі підрозділи експеримент з
інтеграції в
дослідницькі європейські дослідницькі простори ух
викладач  Управління
науки та інновацій
це допомагає нам покращити нашу діяльність у
напрямку української систематики
я знову попрошу всіх вимкнути
мікрофони, коли ви
будете в нашій розмові, дуже дякую вам,
і це допомагає нам забезпечити
деяку систематичну роботу над помилками
інтеграція
також дуже важлива для посилення
нашого конкурентного механізму фінансування досліджень
і psf uh заявила, що
національний дослідницький фонд може бути
дуже важливим елементом цієї системи
на даний момент наприкінці 2020 року ми знаємо,
що
nrf успішно
здійснив перші два дзвінки
протягом цього року і надано
загальний
бюджет на 20 250 млн. укр.
скарги,
і дуже важливо, що план, ми
сподіваємося, що фонд зможе
посилити свій потенціал і
більше дати більше ух і більше різних
інструментів
для українських дослідників сьогодні буде,
а
пізніше в рамках програми ми
матимемо промову  директора фонду
Олігаполотської також дуже
важливо
надати нові механізми, пропозицію
розподілу фінансування між
університетами
та науковими установами, на
даний момент
нам вдалося розробити такий механізм
для вищої освіти
ух для вас для університетів,
де ми маємо конкретні показники
також було
визначено невірне око,
і від цього залежить функція університету,
також оцінка
університетів,
яка триває, буде першим кроком
для забезпечення
фінансування досліджень на основі ефективності
в секторі вищої освіти також
існує  Системи державної
оцінки всієї діяльності
в наукових установах на
даний момент немає  Це пов’язано з фінансуванням,
але в принципі це дуже важливий
крок, який
також входив до рекомендацій щодо
надання такої оцінки
з метою уточнення рівня
наукової діяльності різних
установ,
також дуже важливо
вдосконалити систему
експертизи та залучити  іноземні експерти
на даний момент це буде зроблено для
оцінки вищих навчальних
закладів ух їхньої наукової
діяльності та
Національного дослідницького фонду
ну на даний момент хтось ділиться
своєю презентацією не моєю ну добре,
вибачте, у вас дуже милі миші
ви бачите зараз добре, і
зараз є тверде зобов’язання
забезпечити реформування системи
національних академій наук,
на даний момент міністерство створило
кілька
робочих груп з реформування
Національної
академії аграрних наук педагогічних
наук,
а також Національної академії наук.  наук
україни
ух Національна академія наук
україни  У нас є своя група з
реформування та набір пріоритетів,
у рамках яких інші академії сектору
академії працюють з міністерством,
і ми
розробили плани такого реформування, починаючи
з деяких більш формальних та організаційних
речей і,
звісно, з наукової за
нятості  вдосконалення наукової
діяльності цих науковців,
звичайно, ми розуміємо, що дуже
важливою є підтримка молодих
дослідників, на даний момент
ми розробили деякі положення
, щоб
допомогти або надати деякі інструменти
додаткові інструменти для підтримки
молодих дослідників
і це також дуже важливо
переосмислити розуміння того, хто такий молодий
дослідник, і
дати йому як визначення
не на основі віку, а й
на рівні кар’єрного етапу в
Кореї,
і все це є одним із
пріоритетів, якщо
говорити про інноваційний порядок денний
е, протягом 2019 року була
розроблена
та зроблена їхня національна стратегія,
прийнята нац  Національна стратегія інноваційного
розвитку
до 2030 року на даний момент уряд
працює над
прийняттям плану з дотриманням плану,
і дуже важливо зробити цю
роботу системною, тому що дуже
важливо
надати інструменти, які допоможуть
українським
інноваторам мати більше можливостей,
звісно  це
розвиток дослідницької та
інноваційної інфраструктури є
одним з ключових викликів на даний момент,
і за ці роки не так багато
було зроблено
в цій проблемі, але ми сподіваємося, що те,
що ми робимо зараз
, схоже на проекти
Концепції державної програми
розвитку дослідницької інфраструктури та
концепція політики
розвитку інфраструктури
будуть першим кроком
на шляху до нашого
найсистематичного шляху до розвитку
дослідницької та інноваційної
інфраструктури
добре, це все
з реалізацією psf ми сподіваємося,
що
протягом цього та наступного року ми
зробимо більше, і тепер я зроблю це
ну,
дуже важлива частина також
рекомендацій з аналізу psf, але
також для всієї повітряної та очної політики України,
це інтеграція України в
європейський
дослідницький простір, звичайно, міжнародне
співробітництво
для нас, включаючи європейський дослідницький
простір, є однією з основних
складових  наша національна політика, я
дам короткий огляд того, що ми
робимо зараз,
а також які
перспективи наших наступних
кроків в рамках інтеграції до епохи
2020 року міністерство разом
з експертами
Національної ради  з науки і
техніки або з
членами наукового комітету ради
і е,
що експерти оновили
дорожню карту української інтеграції до епохи
ми плануємо прийняти її
до кінця цього року, а також
ми готові зрозуміти  що цей
документ
є так само, як і перша платформа,
яка встановлює пріоритети, що потрібно для
визначення
деяких важливих kpis нашої інтеграції
та пізно
r дуже важливо також працювати з
виробниками та іншими зацікавленими сторонами, а також з
експертами та науковцями, щоб зробити
кожен крок
, згаданий у дорожній карті,
реальністю
та забезпечити необхідне фінансування,
необхідне законодавство та необхідний
рівень розуміння всіма
зацікавленими сторонами
а також ми знаємо, що
в рамках нашого спілкування з Європейською
комісією, що
нова ера введена у
вересні цього року, і дуже
важливо синхронізувати майбутні компоненти
політики нової ери з нашими національними
пріоритетами,
тому ми плануємо на  початок
наступного року,
щоб розпочати консультації з нашими
партнерами в європейській комісії, щоб
коригувати цілі нової ери
та розробити нову ітерацію
дорожньої карти ери, тому що
ера розвивається,
для нас
дуже важливо сформувати нашу політику в  ця
політика інтеграції епохи
еволюціонує синхронізовано,
щоб прискорити темп до
інтегрована українська система штату Іллінойс
в епоху,
ми прагнемо
визначити найважливіші та ефективні кроки, які
допоможуть нам у
короткій перспективі забезпечити
ефективний достаток у епоху,
ми зараз беремо участь у
комітеті ірак і
хм, інші комітети епохи, і
дуже важливо
побудувати це в такому стилі все ще є
викликом, але
ми будемо працювати над цим протягом
кількох наступних місяців, щоб забезпечити, щоб
не лише наші експерти були частиною
спілкування в цих комітетах,
але  також, що наші українські
експерти та делегати мають чітке
розуміння системи
комунікації в нашій країні, тому
що дуже важливо
вдосконалити систему інформаційного
циклу, щоб інформація, яка
там отримана
, обговорювалася з відповідними експертами
в Україні
та зміцнювало наше розуміння  ну, що
робити
і як це зробити
, також важливо визначити пріоритети
інвестицій, тому що зараз
Як ви знаєте, рівень фінансування науки та страху
Варанді не надто низький порівняно з країнами-
членами ЄС та багатьма іншими
країнами,
тому дуже важливо
розуміти,
де ми знаходимося, де, де  ми можемо
інвестувати
та отримати більше, тому
один із таких інструментів, серед інших,
це
буде фінансування в межах
грошей відшкодування горизонту 2020 року,
ми зараз працюємо
над прийняттям необхідного
законодавства і
як тільки воно  буде можливо, ми
запустимо дзвінок у ньому, і
це буде зосереджено на тих
людях, які
були успішними або принаймні
намагалися взяти участь у горизонті
2020, щоб вони мали
певний рівень  потенціал для
подальшого розвитку, тому це також один
із способів визначити
пріоритети фінансування, а також ми прагнемо
провести новий psf,
ух, зараз, ух, перший був
про всю систему випадкових барвників заліза
в Україні та систему  о  f
політику в ній,
і тепер ми хочемо зосередитися на дослідницькій
інфраструктурі, тому що, як я вже згадував
раніше,
ми зараз ніби намагаємося надати якийсь
систематичний погляд на розвиток
дослідницької інфраструктури,
і зараз ми просимо Європейську
комісію допомогти нам у
дослідженні.  е-е,
прилади та кращі практики
найкращі практики, які
вони мають в Європейському Союзі, щоб ми
врахували їх, коли ми будемо
розробляти наші
у-у-у, наші інструменти, у-у, також,
звичайно, участь
міжнародних ініціатив з аеродинаміки
є пріоритетом для нас на  зараз
ми закінчуємо з горизонтом 2020 та
євроатомом, але, звичайно, ми почали
працювати
над нашою майбутньою участю в
дослідницькій та навчальній програмі Horizon Europe та uraton.
Наші європейські колеги в їхніх
спільних комітетах
сказали, що вони
думають, що наша робота в межах  ці
два інструменти, ці програми
були дуже хорошими, і
ми входимо в 10 найкращих асоційованих
країн  два дні тому у нас було яскраве ух
і використовуйте на цьому, що у нас є перший
український uh
erc consolidator uh grant
uh досягнення, так що ми маємо гарну ух
ситуацію, щоб почати нашу участь
у наступній програмі і
від міністра ми робимо
все, що ми
потрібно зробити, щоб зробити
це реальністю, і, звичайно, цього року
епоха
була зосереджена на їхній
боротьбі з Халідом 19 є, і
вони дуже швидко розробили план дій
Corona Arab West Corona,
і дякую  Ви до Європейської
комісії Україна були
серед асоційованих країн і
мали
можливість почути та знати,
що роблять інші
країни для
вирішення пантомічної ситуації, я сподіваюся, що
українські дослідники мають
всю необхідну інформацію
в рамках цього  План дій щодо ризику коронавірусу в епоху
та
інформація, надана європейськими
колегами на відповідному веб-сайті,
також є нова дуже амбітна
програма європейської зеленої угоди,
і ми мали  День немовляти в цей день,
і, звичайно, дуже важливо, щоб
українські вчені та новатори
та
всі можливі зацікавлені
сторони мали всю необхідну кількість інформації
про
ці програми та спробували власні в рамках
цих програм,
тому що ми знаємо, що успіх це
такий  в таких інструментах у роботі
та протягом багатьох років і багатьох випробувань,
тому
ми сподіваємося, що ми покращимо з
боку міністерства та уряду, ми покращимо
поширення інформації між
Європейським Союзом
та українськими зацікавленими сторонами і, звичайно,
ми надихаємо,
що хочемо  щоб надихнути українських
вчених-новаторів спробувати
в цій діяльності, тож якщо вони всі
на даний момент, я думаю,
що можна поставити кілька запитань
або зробити кілька коротких зауважень,
будь ласка, напишіть у вікні чату,
якщо у вас є ну
що  сказати зараз або запитати на
даний момент,
добре, щоб у нас була дуже
цікава
і довга програма на сьогодні, тому я думаю,
що
ми не можемо  w рухатися далі ii думаю,
що учасники о,
було б гарною ідеєю поділитися своїми
я бачу, що легше добре, ух, поділитися
своїми
ідеями у вікні чату, можливо, пізніше,
коли
буде деяка кількість запитань
або зауважень  у нас буде час,
щоб обговорити це, так що, будь ласка, не соромтеся
спілкуватися у вікні чату, а також я бачу,
що права рука
таїтянина говорить одночасно, будь ласка, відкрийте
свій
мікрофон і скажіть "
ні" зараз ні добре,
дуже дякую  багато,
і я думаю, що ми можемо
розпочати наступний
розділ європейської програми, і
вибачте,
я думаю, що це працює з невеликим постом,
і тому я не можу говорити справді
вчасно,
але я думаю, що дуже важливо
пов'язати українську науку
з європейською  програми, а також
співпрацювати в Україні і
якимось чином створювати кластери також в
україні,
на наукових результатах і
наукових програмах, які ми маємо, тому що
часто ми не
бачимо взагалі, що відбувається  ens в ukraine,
і тому це може бути єдине,
що можна додати
до своєї презентації, дуже
дякую,
добре, колеги, тоді я попрошу
пана доктора Андрея Рагулу розпочати наступний
розділ
огляду участі України в
горизонті 2020,
дякую  дуже міс
бісвашенко я не знаю, чи всі можуть
бачити мене в Інтернеті зараз,
мабуть, так добре,
тому я радий
отримати слово, і гм,
вітаю всіх вас, пані та панове,
це мій обов'язок сьогодні  розпочати
е-е-е наступний розділ обговорення
та модерація цієї дискусії навколо
участі України в горизонті
2020, якісь результати
та обговорення
найважливіших для України тем сьогодні
я радий бачити
через екрани багатьох знайомих людей, так що е-е
Мені приємно ще раз
вітати всіх вас послухати,
що ми робимо на горизонті
2020 протягом п’яти років,
тому наприкінці 2020 року
Україна брала участь і бере участь
у  багато спільних заходів з європейськими
партнерами
лише для того, щоб обговорити загальну участь
у програмах eu r
and i та
узагальнити перші результати горизонту та
участі українських інституцій
компаній
та організацій у цій великій
європейській програмі, звичайно, ми розглядаємо
певні
результати, тому що ми намагаємося
розглянемо нашу участь у майбутній
україні, ух у майбутній європейській
програмі, яка є uh horizon europe,
тому що ми провели багато випробувань, щоб передати
наші знання
та дати наше розуміння
того, як ми бачимо участь України
в загальному європейському
науково-технологічному ландшафті.
хотіла б
запропонувати слово Олена
Ково директор
Національного інформаційного центру
з питань науково-технічного співробітництва україни eu
uh для вашої інформації Олена
Ково багато років сприяла
співпраці між україною та
європейськими інституціями, і
вона досягла багато успіхів
у цій діяльності, перш ніж вона  дуже
досвідчений
леді та особа та офіцер, звичайно,
доклавши корисних зусиль
до переваг
участі України
в європейській науково-технічній
діяльності
olenna koval будь ласка, потік за вами. О,
велике дякую д Андре і
доброго ранку, і всім,
і моя сьогоднішня презентація
є коротким оглядом  результати H2020
не остаточні остаточні результати будуть
доступні
ближче до другої половини
наступного року
ii думаю,
[Музика]
ця інформація була підготовлена на ос
ові баз да
их за квартал після 914
звінків, здійснених європейською ко
ісією з 13 г
удня 2013 року та
включено інформацію про подані
та оцінені пропозиції
до листопада цього року,
незважаючи на конкурентоспроможність
програми вона не втрачає
своєї привабливості ви знаєте всього
дві тисячі двісті чотирнадцять
країн взяли участь
у підготовці проектних
пропозицій
сто сімдесят шість
з яких залишилися в  пропозиції
, які були позитивно оцінені
та т  організація підписала грантові
угоди
близько 900 000 заявок
у поданих прийнятних пропозиціях,
понад 140
000 з яких залишилося на фінансування
з бюджетом 58
млрд євро
Зведені дані, опубліковані європейською
комісією,
включають результати участі
в горизонті 2020 для
асоційованих держав-членів ЄС  країни країни-
кандидати, країни-кандидати
та треті країни про
ви можете побачити на слайдах, що близько
90 відсотків бюджету,
а саме 52,4
мільярда євро припадало на
організацію від
європейського союзу, решта
бюджету
близько 10 відсотків, а саме
5,7 мільярдів євро –
це контракт  уклала контракт з
організацією з-
за меж асоційованих країн-кандидатів
– треті країни відповідно
до високої частки
поданих високоякісних пропозицій
Швейцарія є найпривабливішою
успішною
асоційованою країною з
4 000 проектів,
за нею йдуть Норвегія та Ізраїль
серед неасоційованих країн  найуспішнішим
є американський фолло  у березні 2015 року
україна стала новим членом
затінених країн,
відтоді
українська організація може повноцінно
брати участь у горизонті 2020 на
рівних з організаціями країн-членів
ЄС згідно з результатом
264 українські організації
взяли участь у підготовці  з близько
2 000 прийнятних проектних пропозицій
з двома хм
і півтисячи заявок,
153 організації з яких
отримали фінансування
наступного року
[Музика]
недавнє фінансування підтримано на мить
підтримали 203 проектні
проекти з 286
заявками з бюджетом з
внеском ЄС для української
організації
організація 37,5
млн євро загальна вартість проекту
була
участю української організації близько
2,5 млрд
євро зокрема українська
організація
координатори 20 років
вибачте,
зникли презентація
вибачте, зникли презентація
зникла
добре не
гаразд,
будь ласка, продовжуйте так так
наступний наступний
т  дякую вам,
організація з україни
взяла участь у підготовці
проектної пропозиції приблизно в усіх
симетричних сферах 2020 року, найбільша
частина бюджету у залишених для
фінансування проектів надходить із
рівня соціальних викликів, загалом
85 проектів із 107 заявками
утримують її  для фінансування з внеском ЄС
понад 13
мільйонів євро тоді наука
з um 63 проект
85 застосування нового внеску
з бюджетом 11 мільйонів євро є
промисловим лідером
з uh, яка
основна діяльність від досліджень до ринку
з фокусом на інноваційній
діяльності з  гм
з 26 проектами і 42
заявками в новому внеску 6,49
млн євро наступний слайд
знову ух левова частка
громадськості ух лазерної лінії частка претендентів
посилалася на
дії марі ескладос каррі реакції марі
кладовські традиційно популярні серед
українських вчених з
часів участі в fb7  ця
програма традиційно висока і успішна
Україна здобула t  Найбільше фінансування
понад 10 мільйонів євро для
451 з участю uh 73
uh uh
успішним uh також є
такими пріоритетами, як проект Energy
uh 25 з участю 33
і 3,46
мільйонів євро кліматичні зміни
кліматичного середовища з uh
19 uh проектом
і 2,5
мільйонами євро транспортного uh  12
проектів із 22
участю та 4,12
мільйона героїв також
[Музика]
успішна м-м-а участь це
участь української установи
в цьому середньому інструментальному курсі та
гнила програма наступний слайд, будь ласка,
гм категорія системи фінансування для
проекту горизонту 2020
визначає тип проекту та
основні принципи
щодо участі та
розподілу коштів на науково-інноваційні дослідження
українська організація найбільш активно
бере участь
у підготовці пропозицій до
науково-
інноваційних дій
uh 57
проект з 65 заявками
майже чверть проектів
проект координаційних та супроводжуючих
дій 52
проекти з 65 заявками
потім  інноваційна діяльність  14
проектів з 26
додатками, як я сказав,
гм, гм, маріус гладоська
косметичний клуб реакція е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е-е,
13 проектів, також
українська інституція досягла успіху
в рамках ініціативи з
дрон-техніки Школи
було підписано одну угоду в галузі
енергетики з м-м  55
тисяч ваших внесків і
вашого внеску та грантової угоди
грантові угоди в галузі
транспорту
з внеском ЄС близько 3 мільйонів
євро
також півтора близько півмільйона
євро перейдіть на дослідницьку інфраструктуру
наступний слайд будь ласка,
ну добре український  участь
у горизонті 2020 року переважає
приватний сектор,
потім дослідницька організація, організації
вищої та середньої освіти.
Половина фонду йде
організаціям приватного сектору,
21 відсоток дослідницьким
установам, близько 20
відсотків університетам та університетам
і
чотири  відсотка державним установам
майже третина всієї уч  участь
у проекті за допомогою пари з України,
які отримують фінансування, належать малим
і середнім підприємствам
бюджет 11
понад 11 мільйонів євро
наступний слайд
одним із найцікавіших
сайтів рамкових програм
європейського союзу
, безумовно, є можливість співпраці
з
науковцями з  у всьому світі
багато багато дослідників інноваційні
вчені з різних міст
україни
співпрацюють з
усіма континентами майже з усіма країнами
асоційованих країн Європейського союзу
ех
більшість проектів
більшість проектів, координованих
представниками
країн, пов'язаних з горизонтом 2020,
належать Швейцарії  ізраїль норвегія
серед країн ЄС це Велика
Британія Німеччина Іспанія
Франція італія та Бельгія це
з цими країнами ЄС Україна має
найактивнішу співпрацю в програмі
наприклад з
Францією 600 спільна участь з Німеччиною
близько 500
500 спільна участь іспанія 400
спільна участь італія  400
гр  t britain 200 belgium 200.
Тож я хотів би скористатися
цією можливістю, ви бажаєте всім
нам усім нашому закладу університетський
інститут якнайкращих ух,
позитивних результатів у вас, перший прихід,
рамкова програма горизонт європа,
тепер я передаю слово гіду Вікторії,
дякую  за вашу увагу, olenna,
дуже дякую
за вашу захоплюючу презентацію,
багато ілюстрацій та малюнків, як ми
робимо нашу діяльність у горизонті 2020,
ще раз дуже дякую за вашу
презентацію,
дуже дякую за те, що ви
хочете просто
згадати, що результати горизонту 2017
показують, що  Україна захищає сьому
позицію
серед 16 країн асоціації з
точки зору
дякую Вікторії за представлення,
тому мій сьогоднішній обов’язок – це лише
презентація міжнародної
співпраці
в рамках дослідницьких установ
на горизонті 2020 року,
тому я вирішив почати з самого
початку
діяльності України в ЄС
і перша угода, нагадаю вам
, була підписана в 2002 році, яка
створює правову основу для  r науково
-технічного співробітництва між
дослідницькими організаціями Європейського Союзу
та українськими інститутами
, а також державними органами,
тоді
ми перейшли на блискучу угоду
між
Європейським Союзом та Україною
саме про участь України
в союзних програмах,
включаючи горизонт 2020, величезну
рамкову
програму для досліджень та інновацій
між  14 і 20.
тому ми пам'ятаємо цю грандіозну подію,
коли комісар Маядуш
приїхав до Києва заради
підписання цього документа,
якого дуже
чекали чи вітали
наукова спільнота України,
тоді 2016 рік
був дуже продуктивним, ми уклали
дві угоди з наукової науки  та
технологічна співпраця
з європейським атомним енергетичним співтовариством,
а другий був підписним документом
між Національною академією України
та Академією наук України
та DG Grc я досі пам'ятаю
осінь 16 року, коли Володимир Шуха
був тут у Києві і знову
досяг успіху в переговорах  просто
т  o продовжувати співпрацю
зі спільним дослідницьким центром у європейській
комісії,
дозвольте мені знову зосередити вашу увагу
на участі в Horizon 2020.
Цікаво, що дослідницькі організації,
такі як установи різних
академій
та установ, розташованих
в університетах, взяли
участь у майже 40 відсотків
uh 40 відсотків заходів
і подав багато проектів
і виграв кілька проектів з європейськими
вибачте, який був коментар, з'явився,
добре, я продовжую
, але приховані учасники дослідження -
це невеликі компанії,
дивлячись на великий сірий сектор на цій
цифрі,
це точно пов'язано з участю малих компаній,
але ця маленька компанія  дуже
часто пов’язані з
вищими навчальними закладами та академічними
установами, тому ми маємо
дуже глибоке
співробітництво між науковими
організаціями та малими
компаніями сьогодні. Ой,
я хотів проілюструвати участь
у горизонті
з найменшою з
найвидатніших наукових організацій
в Україні, тому з 14 до  l
20 багато з них
брали участь у багатьох проектах
вони національні наукові центри в
Харківському фізико-технічному інституті
одна з найвідоміших
науково-дослідних організацій в Україні потім
космічний
інститут Національної академії
наук
брав участь у багатьох проектах тоді
Національної академії наук  України
в цілому
в проектах CSA
та національних
інституцій просто
заклади біля політехніки в
льві та політехніки в києві
та інших відомих
науково-дослідних інститутів в
україні наступний,
тому на цій діаграмі я хочу
показати зміну діяльності
протягом 14-20 років.  до сьогодні,
скільки проектів і підписаних угод у
нас було на цьому фантастичному
шляху, тому що це було вперше,
коли ми масово
брали участь в європейській
науковій програмі, тож ви бачите, що ми мали
більші чи менші успіхи і іноді
падають, проте
ми все ще
підтримуємо досить високий рівень  участь,
крім того, у нас є лідери
серед наукових організацій
України
у кожній галузі
науки наступна
ми беремо участь у всіх трьох
стовпах чудове наукове промислове
лідерство
та соціальні зміни, звичайно, ми зустріли
багато викликів на цьому шляху
на цьому ех величезні
зусилля української організації
співпрацювати та конкурувати
з європейськими
інституціями, проте
ми  зібрано непогані
колекції проектів, які демонструють
безперечно високий рівень науки
та інституцій та
бажання продемонструвати
наші досягнення в
розвитку технологій та створенні прав
інтелектуальної власності
до того, як 50 відсотків учасників становлять
невеликі компанії,
усі вони мають власні патенти
та іншу інтелектуальну власність,
яка корисна  на європейському ринку,
і перш ніж ми сподіваємося на розширення
цієї участі та передачу
знань від наукових
установ компаніям, а також розвивати нові бізнеси
та розвивати нову галузь на
основі найвищого рівня дослідницької
діяльності наших установ,
тоді ми також дуже активні  у суспільних
викликах та програмах,
що стосуються розвитку суспільства
, а також цифри, що демонструють нашу
участь у фінансуванні та кількість проектів,
також дають нам
оптимізм очікувати
наступної програми Європа горизонту Європи,
я хотів би показати деякі
види діяльності національної академії
Наукові
установи в горизонті 2020 року
ви бачите, ми досягли
майже 30 30
uh два проекти на рік,
це непоганий показник для
академічних установ, тому що
ми також маємо певні проблеми
всередині національної академії наук, і ми
просто
працюємо з реформуванням заради
покращення  цей інноваційний клімат
у академічній
діяльності, де намагаючись
розвивати не тільки дуже хороші дослідження
або дослідницьку діяльність найвищого рівня,
ми також зосереджуємось на прикладних дослідженнях та
академічних установах,
боротьба за кращі проблеми
та кращу
продуктивність технологічних розробок
заради нової промисловості в Україні
наступний
ех співпраця країн на горизонті 2020
року, як іл  зображено на цій
кольоровій фігурі,
а квадрат, кожен квадрат,
відноситься до іншої
країни в Європі, і
мені приємно, що Україна
знаходиться в середині цього списку,
тому наш квадрат не найменший,
це є результатом
української традиційної науки досить
сильної
наука виникла з минулого,
і ми все ще маємо потужну наукову
організацію та культуру
для проведення досліджень
та високого рівня розуміння
та дуже кваліфікованих фахівців, які
працюють у різних галузях
науки
у фізиці, хімії, біології,
матеріалознавстві та багатьох інших
дисциплінах,
і це результат
нашої широкої участі, незважаючи на те, що
ми
щойно почали займатися європейськими
проектами в порівнянні з попередніми
роками, коли це було досить спонтанно,
а не
систематично, наступний слайд, будь ласка,
я хотів би показати вам найкращі
приклади найбільші приклади
успішної співпраці
ну перш за все  Я хотів
поговорити про європейські мережі,
тому що європейські програми люблять горизонт
займався в першу чергу
мережами платформ та
іншою великомасштабною
діяльністю, тому в першу чергу я хотів
підкреслити нашу діяльність у космічних
дослідженнях і лідера в цій
діяльності Інститут космічних досліджень
Національної
академії наук України та
національного
космічного агентства  Україна нагадаю
, що
Україна не
була космічної країною, тому що у нас
є власне виробництво космічних ракет і
велике
конструкторське бюро, як правило,
в місті Ніпро та
багато інших конструкторських бюро, які займаються
розробкою різноманітних супутників
і супутників для космічного застосування.
ця
європейська мережа, про
яку ми говоримо про великі дані, які генеруються
in situ, або супутникові платформи
збираються та досягаються за допомогою
безлічі систем та інструментів,
що ускладнює
обмін даними та знаннями між
зацікавленими сторонами та політиками
для підтримки ключових економічних і соціальних
секторів
до появи платформи
Планета ери приваблива
тим, що вона зміцнює європейські
дослідження  h
область у сфері спостереження за Землею,
безумовно, українські інституції
здатні внести
величезний внесок у
розвиток цієї платформи
та надати багато технологій,
корисних для цифровізації
спостереження за Землею, і
надати багато корисних продуктів
, які будуть використовуватися
для розвитку  різних регіонів
та розвиток технологій
та розвиток цифрових
технологій передусім
для спостереження за ефективністю використання ресурсів
та зміни клімату та, звичайно,
забруднення атмосфери СО2
та багато інших завдань, пов'язаних із
космічним спостереженням нашої
планети наступне місце, де
займається аеропланета  з
розвитком розумних міст та
стійкого суспільства
ресурсоефективного управління екологічними
змінами та екологічними
договорами на даний момент
aeroplanet
включає 17 проектів, поданих з України
та включає 12 учасників,
тому це хороший внесок, і ми очікуємо
фантастичних результатів, оскільки наступний
цей проект або  профі  gram європейська
мережа для
спостережень наших складних планет,
спрямована на розробку методів і
технологій для
комплексного використання даних спостережень наземного та повітряного простору
для моніторингу прогнозування природних ресурсів
та аналізу екстремальних
природних
і техногенних явищ,
ми очікуємо зробити висновок
щодо моніторингу агри,
ми очікуємо оцінку  приземного
забруднення
повітря аерозольних частинок та приземної
зони ми очікуємо спостерігати
токсичність реального диму
за допомогою різних оцінених за допомогою біологічних
об'єктів, тому в цю діяльність
бере участь 35 партнерів з 11
європейських країн та 8 установ
з України наступний,
будь ласка, наступний.
victoria, будь ласка, наступний, дякую,
вибачте попередній,
будь ласка, надайте мені попередній так
не це ii хотів би поговорити
про великі дані так,
для хмари даних c так,
наступний приклад продуктивної
співпраці
стосується хмари даних c
подальшим розвитком  загальноєвропейської
інфраструктури для морської  d
відзначають, що менеджмент також має справу з дуже специфічною, але дуже великою
науковою діяльністю,
включаючи
спеціаліста з багатьох галузей сучасної
науки та технологій,
тому було
створено понад 100 морських центрів обробки даних,
які займаються забезпеченням виявлення
та доступу до ресурсів даних
для всіх європейських  дослідники
бачать, що мережа даних є ключовою
інфраструктурою, яка керує кількома
порталами європейської мережі морських
спостережень
і даних,
тому ми очікуємо також
багато позитивних результатів
від українських інституцій, що
впливають безпосередньо на
економіку
країни, тому що Україна
є морською країною, але ми очікуємо  більше
на сайті
міжнародного співробітництва розвитку і,
звичайно,
ми хотіли б бути продуктивним партнером
для європейських країн і Європейського
Союзу в цілому
через цю величезну
величезну програму
наступний приклад стосується
гіганта дослідницької та освітньої мережі jn43n
також
великий проект, який
присвячений високим  підключення, необхідне
для спільного
доступу та обробки величезних
обсягів даних,
ці дані генеруються необхідними для
різноманітних дослідницьких та освітніх
спільнот у таких галузях,
як фізика елементарних частинок, біоінформатика,
спостереження за Землею, відкриття наркотиків
, мистецтво та культура,
тому це дуже широкий і дуже багатий
знову ж таки  є в одному великому проекті,
і ми раді взяти участь, і
вже
[Музика]
внесла багато в
гігантський проект, який виріс під час його
взаємодії через gn1 gen2
gn3, а поточна
фаза проекту – це проект j43m,
який передбачатиме
реструктуризацію гігантського великонародного  мережу
через дослідження та
придбання довгострокових неподільних
прав
користування наступний
цей слайд ілюструє, зокрема,
як ми брали участь у е-е-
е частинах гігантського проекту ген для двох
дослідницько-освітньої мережі
та ми брали участь у кількох
проектах, таких як sga
riaa та інші
uh gn41 науково-освітня мережа
uh gen43 науково-освітня мережа,
щоб ви бачили  ілюстрація
того, як українські частини
сприяють загальноєвропейській
діяльності, наступний ii
завершиться зараз,
звичайно, я хотів би згадати
промінь Черенкова телескопа
міжнародний європейський дослідницький
інфраструктурний проект
, цей проект
охоплює мережу
променів черенківського телескопа  які
корисні
для спостережень в ядерній фізиці,
яка частина необхідна для спостереження за
нашим Всесвітом, і ми раді
співпраці з Чехією ірландією,
польщею,
швейцарією і, звичайно, з україною,
наступний,
мабуть, останній слайд,
так, я хотів би подякувати.
за успішну участь і
дякую за те, що вислухали
о мою презентацію дуже дякую
ух як модератора цього розділу
я хотів би представити
академіка Ігоря
Гарсіа, він є заступником
директора науково-дослідного національного наукового центру
Харківського фізико-технічного інституту,
це мій  із задоволенням знову передати
вам слово, хотілося б, щоб
ми б  Я радий слухати ваші
досягнення та
ваш атом, будь ласка,
о, доброго ранку всім,
дякую, пане голова, за ваші теплі
вступні слова
я особисто дуже радий познайомитися з вами,
навіть в онлайн-форматі, і я спробую
керувати
своєю презентацією сам.
щоб показати,
добре
, ви бачите мій мій екран,
так, так, тема моєї
презентації – описати
поточний статус
участі України в програмі дослідження та торгівлі атомом євро,
а як ви знаєте, ваш атом є
дуже важливою та надзвичайно важливою
сферою досліджень для України
в  зокрема тому, що до 60
відсотків
усієї електроенергії в Україні
надходить від атомних електростанцій, а
також екологічних проектів, а
також дуже важлива для нашої країни
дослідницька діяльність євроатому базується
на трьох основних китах,
перш за все,
я маю на увазі прямі дії
спільний європейський центр спільний дослідницький
центр grc
і дві непрямі дії, пов'язані з
зоною поділу, і цей термоядерний,
тож якщо ми маємо  подивіться на вашу
позицію атома в програмі горизонту 2020,
ми побачимо, що ваш атом займає
друге
місце за участю України,
а загальний внесок ЄС
перевищує чотири мільйони чотири і сім мільйонів
євро,
а ваша частка атома в усій участі в горизонті 2020
становить
близько 12,5 відсотка,
тож  насправді одна восьма всієї
української діяльності, спільна
діяльність у межах Horizonte пов'язана
з
вашим атомом,
я маю сказати, що надихаю, що
наша участь у вашому атомі насправді
почалася на
два роки пізніше, ніж наша участь у
самій програмі Horizonte 2020, тому що
для участі необхідна додаткова угода  у вашій атомній
діяльності ця угода була підписана
в червні 2016 року, але
навіть до цього ми маємо непоганий
приклад,
це новий проект, який пов'язаний з
управлінням
ядерним паливом, і він був виконаний в
нашому інституті в Національному науковому центрі
Харківського фізико-технічного інституту
але це початок нашої участі, ну
відразу
кілька  додаткові проекти, які ми
запускаємо,
серед них libra fusion,
за кожен злиття якого я відповідаю, зараз
займає в
основному одну чверть
усієї участі України
у вашому атомному бюджеті я маю на увазі
тоді в 2018 році
інфраструктурний проект ua в європі був
запущений
видатну підтримку створення
і
діяльність Національного контактного пункту Європи в Україні,
і цей національний контактний пункт
був створений
знову в мультфільмах з фізики та
техніки, і ви бачите, що
з початку нашої участі
у вашій атомній програмі
в 2017 році ми можемо спостерігати досить хороший
прогрес, ми  все ще маємо,
можливо, навіть експоненційний ріст нашої
участі,
і ви бачите, що в цьому році в 2020 році ми
маємо 10
проектів, які ми запускаємо
нажаль за 10 хвилин я б я
не зможу описати
результати у всьому цьому проекті
я  лише коротко згадав деякі з них,
як-от eurofusion
ui в європі європи та prezis,
який ілюструє українські
можливості та
деякі хороші приклади нашої залучення
до географії
дослідницької програми Європи, коли ми говоримо про
термоядерну
активність вашого атома, вона сильно
зосереджена
на науковому забезпеченні
міжнародного експериментального
нагрівача термоядерного реактора, який зараз
будується в Кадараші та
Франції в районі Марселя,
тому  цей пристрій має
на меті отримати
першу плазму в 2025 році
в кінці 2025 року, і очікується,
що він зможе забезпечити
500 мегават термоядерної потужності
не в електроенергії, але
демонстраційна демонстрація пристрою наступного покоління
зможе бути підключена до електричних систем
Європи
european union uh є господарем проекту обігрівача
і фактично забезпечує понад
50 відсотків
загального фінансування їдця і,
звісно, Європейський союз бажає досягти хо
ошого прогресу з наступним єв
опейським пристроєм, який називається nemo demo facil
ty, і разом з uh р
зом з діяльністю stokamak це
уде  бути токамаком, і
я повинен сказати, що ключовою
стратегічною метою термоядерної енергії
є с  забезпечити наше людство практично
безвуглецевою і практично безпечною
електрикою, як на нашому сонці, і
навіть у
разі дуже сильної аварії чи
поломки не потрібно організовувати
якусь евакуацію населення, щоб
це ілюструє безпеку цієї стратегічної
енергії для  для нашого
людства, тому серед конкурентоспроможних
підходів, звичайно, я повинен згадати
активність
зоряної системи та законний толерант надпровідності Wenderstein
7x
був введений в експлуатацію в Німеччині
в Griezweld, ним керує
Інститут фізики плазми Макса Планка, і ви бачите
приклад,
як це було запущено.  і я повинен сказати,
що цей старт був
надзвичайно вдалим, тому що навіть для
першої
плазми досягнута температура електронів була
100 мільйонів градусів,
а температура іонів 20 мільйонів градусів,
що в п'ять разів вище, ніж на нашому
сонці, до речі,
і завдяки цьому досить успішний
старт
активність прискорювача також є одним з
пріоритетів
у програмі термоядерного синтезу вашого атома
i вже m  зазначив, що ми почали на два
роки
пізніше, ніж наша участь у
Horizon 2020,
але ми успішно
приєдналися до консорціуму eurofusion, який
є основним органом для виконання програми
Eurofusion 2020,
і цей консультант
представляє всі країни європейського
союзу та навіть пов’язані з ним  такі країни, як
Україна та Швейцарія, і ми маємо
20 бенефіціарів у
консорціумі eurofusion uh і більше
пов'язаних третіх сторін, тому це досить
велика
організація, і в рамках програми yoratan fusion
Національна академія наук
має статус власника програми, тому що
всі українські термоядерні та ефективні
дослідження  діяльність в основному здійснюється в рамках
академічної установи, і kapt є
найбільшим
наш центр бос інфузії та поділу
був призначений керівником програми для
цієї діяльності від імені України це
не означає, що
участь kpt брала участь самостійно,
ми створили український дослідницький підрозділ
у європейському синтезі та ми
залучати інших  Український інститут, як
в Національній
академії наук України, так
і наші провідні університети
до цієї програми, і тепер у нас є чотири
організації в нашому дослідницькому підрозділі,
окрім інституту ядерних
досліджень
КПТ, які займаються певною важливою діяльністю
в термоядерному синтезі  теорія, а також в описі
поведінки плазми токамака Харківський
національний університет ух Каражан брав участь у
кількох робочих пакетах
консорціуму fiora fusion, а також живих
політехнічних
політехнічних національних університетів у
залученні та
діагностиці та контролі та вони розробляють
магнітні датчики для термоядерних застосувань
, зокрема
датчики uh holo bagalub  інститут
теоретичної фізики ух
спільний консорціум лише у 2018 році
і переважно бере участь у освітній
діяльності. Я опишу
цей момент трохи пізніше, а
нещодавно
наш провідний університет Тари Шівченко також приєднався до нашого
консорціуму
та внутрішню угоду про співпрацю
ми підписали
між kapt та  всі наші розважальні
вечірки, ух lynx, тож коли ми
подивимося
на вашу дорожню карту злиття в межах горизонту
2020,
ви знову побачите, що проміжна демонстрація серед
найвищих пріоритетів, а також
діяльність прискорювача
та описуючи нашу участь, я повинен
сказати, що тепер
для нашого інституту академічні інститути
брали участь у  експерименти під час спільного європейського туру реактивних літаків,
який розміщений у колонці в
Оксфордширі
[Музика]
Великобританія, як я вже згадував,
команда relive брала участь у діагностичних
та контрольних
дослідженнях, і вони дуже активно брали участь,
і вони демонструють дуже хорошу
похідну,
дуже позитивну похідну в цьому дослідженні
як у  у плані
наукової діяльності та з точки зору
бюджету,
залученого від європейської комісії
серед
наших пріоритетів діяльності, пов'язаної з акселератором,
робочі пакети акселератора один, який
зосереджений на експериментах на стелараторних
пристроях та прискорювач 2, який
орієнтований на теорію, а також середні
біржові
марки по всьому світу  як tcv у
швейцарії як de  cks, які працюють
у Німеччині та на Заході
у Франції, ми беремо участь у програмі
компонентів, що накладають на плазму, і я повинен
сказати, що
термоядерний синтез - це не тільки проблема фізики плазми
, але це комплексна
програмна
проблема для багатьох галузей науки та
техніки, я просто  Згадав про
надпровідні магніти,
я щойно згадав деякі проблеми, пов’язані зі зварюванням,
деякі матеріали в екстремальних умовах,
тому це поле для
внеску для будь-якого наукового вченого,
яке могло б
вплинути на загальну мету
досягнення безпечної та
практично питання електрики для
для нашого світу важливою особливістю
ваших предметів є те, що
ми розуміємо, що немає науки
без освіти,
і нам потрібно навчати науку наступного
покоління,
тому один із робочих пакетів
присвячений
самій освітній програмі, тому ви відмовляєтеся підтримувати
як докторантів, так і
Аспіранти в
університетах, які здобувають освіту в цьому
районі,
дійсно пішли на злиття  дослідження, тому
я не буду продовжувати такими прикладами
лише для того, щоб продемонструвати, що у
нас досить хороші позиції в
консорціумних дослідженнях і до того ж
україні пощастило, тому що не в усіх
галузях науки, але тут у нас є досить
хороші
експериментальні пристрої українські
прискорювачі, які збираються
на нього та  3 м бере участь у цій
діяльності, ви бачите тут
ці пристрої, і насправді у нас
температура тут може бути 10 мільйонів
градусів, це як
на нашому сонці, тому ми також маємо досить потужний
інструмент для дослідження матеріалів
в екстремальних середовищах, це
квазістаціонарний стан  плазмові прискорювачі
це унікальний інструмент для дослідження
проблем взаємодії з поверхнею плазми, який,
як
очікується, буде реалізований у термоядерному реакторі, як-
от демо-версія Ethereum, у
нас є сильний теоретичний досвід у
нашій країні,
ви бачите тут приклади
участі в нашій діяльності або наші теми дослідження
для різних інститутів  а також для
університетів я не буду торкатися
надто багато уваги до цього моменту ju
Я зазначив, що вона охоплює
практично всі питання сучасної фізики плазми
для високотемпературної плазми для
навчальної діяльності існує спеціальна
платформа
uh освітня мережа, яка називається
viewsnet і Харківський національний університет Каражана
є активними учасниками та провідними
учасниками України
в цій мережі і кожен
рік багато студентів з Каражанського
університету відвідали
різні школи, не цього року,
звичайно, тому що це пандемія, але у них
немає часу,
вони мають час на участь і
можливість брати участь у різних
заходах навіть на онлайн-формах,
приклад використання події pg
для всієї Європи це було
віртуально навіть
протягом двох днів і наші студенти пг
взяли участь
у цьому заході як ще один приклад
корисності цього інструменту
це дистанційне навчання студентів
харківського
каражанського університету в голіанських токамакі в чеському університеті в Празі
не кожен  університет здатний забезпечити
якісну експериментальну
підготовку о  для фізиків це якраз той
випадок,
коли харківська група дистанційно працює
з голем такамака і вони виробляють 55
імпульсів і аналізують результати і готують
спільну роботу про це,
тому для освіти це надзвичайно
важливо для того,
щоб Україна була залучена до цієї
європейської
дослідницької спільноти освітньої спільноти
з іншими європейськими університетами,
які, до речі,
щойно згадані тут як
приклади термоядерного синтезу, дуже хочу
проект, я згадав eu red,
який є спільною європейською програмою
поводження з радіоактивними відходами,
це дуже важливо для України, оскільки
ви знаєте, що у нас є
досить багато  атомних електростанцій
і для нас безпечні є стійкі та
прийнятні для суспільства рішення щодо
поводження з радіоактивними відходами
є дуже важливими, і в цьому проекті,
який було розпочато
в попередньому році цього п'ятирічного
напряму, ми маємо
51 партнера з 23 країн, знову
створений консорціум
під  координація andra france
з україни ми маємо двох бенефіціарів
У
цьому
консорціумі для науково-дослідних інститутів
Національної академії брали участь сторони з інструментарію.
Я знову згадав у ckpt
інститут хімії навколишнього середовища, ще
один проект із
predis, який
був запущений лише цього року на чотири
роки,
і цей консорціум включає 47 партнерів
із
Координатор 18 країн є
технічним дослідницьким центром Фінляндії
і двоє бенефіціарів, які беруть
участь з української сторони, знову ж таки, ці два
інститути
Національної академії наук, але фокус
тут не на
утилізації самих радіоактивних відходів,
а на попередньому обробці
парів відходів, відмінних від ядерного палива  та
високоактивних радіоактивних відходів,
тому я не маю часу говорити більше про
деякі додаткові приклади нашої
участі,
я щойно згадав, що з метою отримання
більш детальної інформації та надання
певної
підтримки та консультацій для українських
дослідників
було створено національний контактний пункт Uh Yorata
в Україні в м.  2017 рік  і ви бачите тут
веб-сторінку цього національного контактного пункту,
а головна назва цього контактного пункту
полягає в тому,
щоб підтримувати участь українських дослідників
у
вашій дослідницькій діяльності з атома, а також
навчання, а також освіту, а також деякі
консультації
для наших дослідників щодо того, як бути
залученими
до ваших  підсумкова діяльність для майбутніх
дзвінків це лише
приклад тренінгів, які ми
організовуємо
навіть у нинішніх умовах
пандемічної ситуації
в онлайн-форматі, і ви бачите, що
в цій навчальній діяльності було залучено багато імпортних, багато міст України
та загальна кількість  кількість учасників
досить
висока, тому, ймовірно, якщо у когось є
додаткові запитання, коментарі або,
можливо, якась інформація,
необхідна для того чи іншого
напряму дослідження в межах вашого автоматичного,
будь ласка, не вагайтеся,
будь ласка, зв’яжіться з Європою, Вашим атомом,
національним контактним пунктом в україні, і ми
будемо
раді допомогти Вам взяти участь
у цій діяльності також тому, що
навіть для наступної програми для горизонту Європи
ваш атом все ще готується до
власної дослідницької програми для цієї наступної
рамкової програми, і ми
привіт
сподіваємося, що
добре, велике спасибі вам, доктор Гаракуша
за вашу захоплюючу, ну
і дуже вичерпну
презентацію ядерної діяльності навколо вашого  атомна
програма,
тому дякую ще раз,
наступна тема
цієї сесії - це просто обговорення
історій успіху,
вузькі місця та живі мішки для
майбутнього, тому я хотів би представити
та дати
недолік відомому фізику
з
Київського національного університету імені Чевченка
професору  Валерій Крашевський він
завідувач кафедри
нанофізики конденсованої речовини
Інституту високих технологій
національного університету Валерій радий вас бачити
і ласкаво просимо на презентацію я
даю вам кіготь
будь ласка добре доброго ранку всім
дякую пане голова за  моє
вступ, це дуже приємно для мене,
і я хотів би
зробити свій подарунок  дуже короткі ви можете
побачити мою презентацію
[музика]
тільки мить ви бачите ні
ні, на жаль, я не знаю,
як, можливо, це залежить від
Вікторії, я не знаю, Вікторія, можливо,
допоможе мені
так, за одну хвилину так
іноземні,
просто я буду  почніть добре,
я представляю в
проекті на славу
Марії Кюрі Скелтон Action 2
і ми беремо участь в рамках
корпоративного наукового партнерства Київський
університет є
невеликим великим підприємством приватного сектора,
але
ця компанія дуже сильно пов'язана
з
національним університетом Рашфінка  Києва
та
п'яти установ Національної академії
наук України
і раніше ми мали один
дуже великий проект carter
в період 2063
uh 2019 uh вуглецевих наноматеріалів
для діагностичних застосувань,
і цей проект був
дуже успішним, і європейська
комісія
включає цей проект  у журналі
європейської комісії
як один із найбільш перспективних проектів,
і після цього ми разом із нашим
колегою вирішуємо  rt, щоб подати новий
проект,
і цей проект ви можете побачити назву
об’єднаних ультрамалих наногібридів для
розширеної стереогностики,
і якщо ви хочете, що це за проект, це
проект спрямований на систематичне
міждисциплінарне дослідження наногібридів металевих вуглецевих
наногібридів для просунутих діагностичних
застосувань,
і ви  можна побачити невелику цифру, яка
вказує на те, що проект є
міждисциплінарним, тому що ми
розробляємо метод синтезу
різних вуглецевих наноматеріалів,
поміщених всередину насипів,
наприклад, для і після
певної фізичної обробки ми можемо отримати
різні позитивні результати в терапії
ракової
тканини і так.  Звичайно, його експеримент
з
мишею та об’єднанням був
пов’язаний з промисловими партнерами з
Греції,
біометричними та академічними дослідницькими групами
з Франції,
будь ласка, перейдіть на наступний слайд, і
я хотів би перейти до наступного слайда, будь ласка, коли
я почну перезапустити подання,
ну минулого року, ми
отримали результат відхилення і
чому, звичайно  зараз дуже важлива
причина негативних результатів
оскільки ми вважаємо, що наш проект
дуже хороший, тому що це дуже важливе
завдання
сьогодні для лікування раку, це дуже
важлива
проблема для нашого світу, і якщо ми
уважно вивчимо
наші бали, то він складається з трьох
типів балів.
ми отримали дуже малу
оцінку, лише 4,2. Вплив –
це друга оцінка, це
показує підвищення потенціалу для
подальшої співпраці в галузі досліджень, вона
знову була не так
високою, а якість
та ефективність впровадження була
приблизно дуже високою, оскільки
максимальна – лише
5,2, але загальний бал був
84. і
ви бачите, що конкуренція
проекту досить сильна
і зазвичай знову ж таки в
кар'єрній діяльності Марі Скодов лише 15
25 відсотків позитивної та успішної
заявки,
а у випадку, якщо ви хочете
покращити якість та отримати
більше вищих балів, необхідно
розглянути всі аспекти
презентації та подання, щоб
покращити професіоналізм  якість проекту
та отримуємо більше балів, ми ретельно
аналізуємо
вузьке місце проекту відповідно до коментарів
підсумкових звітів про відносини,
і ви можете побачити, що ці
роки, коли ми знову надсилаємо, наш бал був
вищим і
ми отримуємо 19 відсотків
і отримуємо успішну заявку, яку ви
можете побачити  Різне, тому що
відхилена та успішна заявка
дуже мала,
тому кожен пункт у
поданнях проекту дуже важливий,
і коли ми
[Музика]
ретельно аналізуємо підсумковий звіт про відносини,
ми вирішуємо з координатором з
університету Клода
Берналилло змінити наш консорціум і
включити колодязь  -відомий інститут
науки і
техніки кераміки з Італії, який
має величезний досвід роботи в центрах
наночастинок з органічного заходу,
і це дозволить
нам збалансувати розподіл другої
людини в консорціумі
та ефективно використовувати інфраструктурних
партнерів для досягнення кращих
наукових результатів.  та технологічна
взаємодоповнюваність партнерських організацій
тому
баланс між другою смугою – це дуже
важливе
завдання, тому що дуже важко знайти
партнерів, які хотіли б
направити багато вчених до різних
установ,
тому що невелика кількість
другого місяця становить один місяць, тому
організація,
яка може бути включена в проекти,
повинна мати такі  можливість відправити
співробітників на довгострокове
відрядження, а для покращення
нашого проекту ми також залучаємо до проекту більше жінок
та молодих вчених,
тому що присутність аспірантів у
проекті
дозволяє організувати другий
для більшої кількості для довгострокової
місії, і це знову ж таки важливо,
тому що  Експерименти з біологічними
експериментами
зазвичай складаються з
не дуже коротких експериментів, тому
вони тривають кілька місяців, як зазвичай,
ми також запрошуємо промислових партнерів
з Греції
до проекту, тому що для нас є любов, щоб
сприяти
нашому розвитку в галузі
мультимодальних власних уявлень для промисловості та
оскільки у співпраці з leon
ми маємо кілька патентів США,
присвячених l  іберація наночастинок
та
розробка методу біовізуалізації
живих клітин, ми запитали
також більш досвідченого брехуна. Брехун є представником
юридичної особи по призначенню
це дуже важливі особи, тому що
ця особа надає багато
корисної інформації для проекту
саме ця особа допомагає у
підготовці адміністративної частини  проект,
тому що
зазвичай проект складається з двох
частин, адміністративна та
наукова частина наукова частина наука не є проблемою, вона
відповідає вченим партнерської
організації, але адміністративна частина
зазвичай дуже специфічна, і для того,
щоб отримати успішне
застосування, необхідно
дуже тісно спілкуватися з
хорошим і сильним
брехуном  що може допомогти
в підготовці адміністративної частини
ми
також багато уваги приділяємо поширенню
результатів проекту
зазвичай українські вчені не люблять
витрачати багато часу на такі моменти і
ми включаємо деякі
пункти, як підготовка прес-релізу
наукова
участь наукові фестивалі
фестивалі інновацій, тип
бізнес-інкубатора тощо тощо,
тому в деяких моментах дуже важливо
покращити оцінку проектів, тому після
завершення нашого покращення ми отримали
хороші результати для успішного
застосування, щоб ми
могли допомогти вам, якщо у вас є якісь
питання для мене, я можу пояснити, як
покращити якість презентації
та подання проектів, тому
дуже
дякую, дуже дякую, Валерія за ваш
дійсний внесок,
і я хотів би представити та надати
слово д-
ру Ігеру Катубі, засновнику
ielts  Solutions llc,
будь ласка, вітаємо,
привіт усім, ви мене чуєте так
супер, я спробую поділитися своїм екраном, чи
можете ви зараз побачити презентацію або ви
бачите, що
команди не лякаються,
ми чекаємо вашої презентації,
іноді здається,
так,
я буду, будь ласка, продовжувати
о
[  Музика
], будь ласка, увімкніть мікрофон,
чи все в порядку з вашим підключенням,
можливо, ми можемо дати трохи часу,
і ми перейдемо до наступного динаміка,
так, я  m тут
[Музика
] проблема з
організаторами презентацій, чи є у вас, я
маю на увазі, я надіслав презентацію, чи можете ви
так, так, так, і я просто увімкніть її, щоб
ви могли просто сказати мені,
коли змінити слайди, добре,
щоб я не  бачу
, ти все ще чуєш мене
так, мене звуть Ігор, я просто хочу, щоб
команди заморожені,
будь ласка, дозвольте говорити наступному спікеру,
я вирішу цю технічну проблему,
і ми повернемося після
цього спікера, добре
звучить непогано, але дозвольте мені
представити та познайомитися з доктором pyro mikhailuk
так привіт всім, ви мене чуєте так,
будь ласка, продовжуйте, ласкаво просимо, щоб
виголосити свою
промову добре розмовляйте це ніби
вчора, ніби Вікторія зв'язалася зі мною, і
перш за все мені хочеться сподобатися  вітаю
всіх з
цим днем, досліджуючи День інновацій
в Україні сьогодні я не знав, що
сьогодні особливий день так звучить весело
і
так, тому я отримав цей грант від консолідатора erc,
ну минулого тижня на
тему хімія
і так  так далеко  це було дуже весело
перебувати в стресі та бюрократичній
напрузі, так,
але так, тому, перш за все, я повинен сказати, що я
закликаю всіх подати заявку на це,
тому що
зараз ми як Україна належить до
цієї європейської асоціації, і
ми  мали право подати заявку, а тоді саме
зараз
Європейський Союз показав, що вони
готові підтримати Україну
з цими проектами,
я б не сказав, що це було так просто,
тому що це було досить важко,
я маю на увазі, що я надіслав пропозицію в січні, а потім
у березні
туди  було схоже на першу оцінку, потім рівень
успіху був
близько 40 відсотків, а потім у
жовтні було схоже
на інтерв'ю з
Європейською комісією
в Брюсселі, і це було законно, як
півгодини досить важко,
а потім так, зараз
підготовка триває  і це досить напружено, я мушу
сказати, що я шкодую про це вже сто разів,
але так, я думаю, що це буде весело,
і я закликаю всіх подавати заявки,
тому що я вірю, що для країни це
лише
ти  Я просто хороша річ,
як для науки взагалі
і як для України загалом, я люблю
мати
ті речі, які показали, що Україна має
законний
науковий потенціал, так,
у цій сфері, тому що я вважаю, що
ми вперше купили цю
річ, і це добре  це добре для
підрядника,
так, тому я можу ще раз привітати
всіх з цим,
і я закликаю всіх подати заявку,
це працює, щоб все було прозоро,
і
так, дякую, Павле,
за вашу появу тут і наші
вітання
з отриманням erc  ну,
це грандіозна подія для
фундаментальної наукової діяльності в
україні,
і питання було б у
тому, що ви пропонуєте erc,
тому що фундаментальні дослідження завжди
на межі
ні, це не було божевільним, я б сказав,
що навіть
дуже просто добре
я розумію, що ми  всі тут мають
різне походження, я хімік,
а справа в тому, що в
хімії найпопулярніший
хімічний структурний мотив  це
молекула бензолу,
ми всі знаємо цю назву
бензол. Справа в тому, що бензол - це
сплощена молекула,
вона двовимірна, а
молекула
бензолу містить кількість добре відомих препаратів,
таких як парацетамол,
аспірин, я зараз приймаю аспірин  як і
будь-який
головний біль, і ми всі це знаємо, і
причина полягає в
тому, чому так добре, це просто історично,
тому що одні з перших
подібних хімічних сутностей, як-от хіміки,
почали добре використовувати як
феноли чи будь-яку іншу сировину, яку
ми знаємо зі школи
це загальна інформація, але
філософська річ полягає в
тому, що ми насправді живемо в
тривимірному світі
, фактично не враховуючи час, коли
ми тривимірні, наші
рецептори тривимірні, але
молекула бензолу двовимірна,
і це звучить  логічно, що
наркотики - це багато ліків двовимірні,
наші рецептори тривимірні, чому
б не розвиватися як
тривимірний
аналог  gs бензолу, і це та
проста ідея,
я вважаю, що зрозуміла всім
ідея ще раз вітаю і
ну так, дякую, бажаю вам успіху у
реалізації цієї ідеї виконання проекту в
цілому
так дуже пишаюся, дякую
добре, давайте повернемося
до  хм, ігор кацуба,
так, дуже дякую,
з технікою все добре
додаток, і тому я не міг
транслювати
так, в основному, це моя презентація
про дивовижний проект, який
ми виграли цього року, це відповідь,
тому ми маємо справу з районами позитивної енергії,
концепція, яка перетворить наші
міста в Європі
на дуже різний рівень
залучення громадян  е, енергетична
жадібність, як вони діють,
так що рішення ми
боролися за те, щоб українські міста були в
цьому конкретному проекті
і б  По суті, ми могли б включити
кілька Донецьк, який знаходиться в Луганській
області
, це регіон, який ми також повинні
інтегрувати в Європу тільки
заради нашої
місії та соціальної відповідальності, тому
наступний слайд, будь ласка, так, я хочу
розповісти трохи про нашу компанію і  успіхи, які
ми маємо, і масштаби цього проекту реагування,
і те, через що ми пройшли правильно, тому
що ви говорите про
вузькі місця, плюси і мінуси перебування
тут на горизонті 2020 року
і розповідь про міністерства
якимось чином е, скажімо,
вони дуже багато запитують  о,
що таке horizon europe, що ми будемо
робити там,
тому наступний слайд, будь ласка,
так, я Solutions є
компанією, орієнтованою на дослідження, заснованою в 2010 році,
тепер я представляю рішення, але
також
я заступник директора Інституту Національної
академії наук
Інститут енергетики Pujo,
ми займаємося
цифровою криміналістичною експертизою, готовність до цифрової криміналістичної експертизи
для багатьох проектів, комерційних проектів,
ми займаємося питаннями конфіденційності та кібербезпеки
в інтелектуальній інфраструктурі  в
основному в цій специфікації в цьому
конкретному проекті ми
займаємося кібербезпекою ми є горизонтальним
партнером
ми маємо справу з кібербезпекою в розумних
містах
наступний слайд, будь ласка,
про мене я я я я був дуже
активним
у європейській сфері  європейські
етапи та університети
ми багато працювали з НАТО з європолом
з кібербезпеки з багатьма ми
організатором семінару з кібербезпеки
та цифрової криміналістичної експертизи в США,
ieee, я організую багато семінарів в
Європі,
читаючи там лекції  я роблю
це, скажімо, хак номер один у прямому ефірі,
ми маємо бути видимими, ми повинні бути
активними в соціальних мережах, нам потрібно
співпрацювати, брати участь і заблокувати,
і бажати, що ситуація є фантастичною
можливістю, тому що
я брав участь у багатьох
брокерських заходах
я маю на увазі, що я багато подорожував правильно, я подорожував
і за останні п’ять років я
відвідав офлайн, скажімо,
ймовірно, 40 брокерських подій, але
цього року я відвідав 40 брокерських заходів
лише онлайн,
і це той самий рівень
ефективності  ефективність, тому
я просто ділюся цією інформацією,
тому що це дивовижна можливість потрапити
на наступний слайд, будь ласка,
це наш проект, ми займаємося
кібербезпекою для розумних міст, тому що розумні
міста
взаємопов'язані, вони використовують багато
персональних даних користувачів  громадяни діляться
цими даними
для міських рад, і ми
забезпечуємо рівень кібербезпеки для всіх
цих
міст в Європі, і я хочу сказати, що
це для нас українське підприємство, яке
займається питаннями кібербезпеки Horizon 2020,
є єдиною можливістю надати
рішення щодо кібербезпеки в європейському
розумному  міста
, немає іншого шляху, тому що ми за
межами Європи, ми є асоційованою країною,
і є багато правил, які
не так багато, які не дозволяють
надавати такі послуги через
регламент Анеси європейський парламент
європейська комісія,
але горизонт 2020  є основою
для доставки
наших рішень до Європи, і
я дуже радий цьому, і я дійсно
вірю, що це  чудова можливість
для
нас бути тут, в україні, робити те, що ми любимо
робити те, що ми в основному робимо
на найкращому рівні та доставити е-е в
Європу,
тому в цьому проекті ми маємо кілька
донечків як помилку,
тому ми розробимо платформи для
енергоефективність для
перетворення енергії для кліматичної
нейтральності
в цій кімнаті в Брюсселі, а потім ми
повторимо в серотоніні,
що є дивовижною можливістю, а також для
українських випадків використання,
і наступний слайд, о, наступного рейсу немає,
тому я буду говорити на цьому
слайді
про можливості  і вузькі місця, тому
Horizon 2020 і Horizon Europe
ваша участь стане автоматичною,
як тільки ви виграєте перший проект і ви
виконуєте,
і ви віддані тому, що ви
пообіцяли,
вас автоматично додадуть до наступних
проектів
через рік через два роки через три роки,
і ви автоматично будете  робити
те, що вам подобається, і проводити
дослідження
, але вам потрібно бути відданим,
вам потрібно
виконати те, що ви обіцяли, і
це ключ до успіху
ну, а також вузькі місця –
це вузьке місце номер один,
я б сказав, що
це рівень англійської мови,
і ми підвищуємо грамотність
у наших командах,
ми намагаємося мати носіїв мови в
нашій команді, і ми найняли одного,
і він  працюючи над цим проектом
, скажімо, тигр, вибачте, у вас
є одна хвилина, щоб закінчити,
так, дякую, тому ми щойно
найняли носія мови та встановили англійську
як основну мову спілкування
в команді,
це як хак номер два,
тому я  бажаю вам усіх
дійсно хороших результатів, будь ласка,
не припиняйте це робити,
і ми можемо допомогти,
ви можете попросити нас про будь-яку допомогу, яка вам потрібна
цього року, ми надіслали понад 20
пропозицій щодо вартісних заходів, що є
дивовижною можливістю  Horizon 2020
innovation actions research and
innovation actions,
і це дійсно чудова
можливість,
і я думаю, що тут нам потрібно досягти більшого успіху,
дякую,
о, дуже дякую за ваш
внесок,
це дійсно дуже цінно  id uh,
і мені потрібно переключитися на іншого
ведучого,
який є містером Алексом Бондаренко, засновником
і головою групи Discovery Group,
будь ласка, у вас є потік протягом п'яти хвилин,
дуже дякую, я поділюся своїм
екраном, будь ласка, дайте мені знати, якщо ви бачите, що
це
можна  ви бачите це зараз так, все
добре, ми це бачимо,
шановні, дуже дякую вам за цю
можливість, щоб я
насправді висловився сьогодні, я хотів би
трохи розповісти вам про нашу компанію
та про нашу історію з фінансуванням з
європейського фінансування  Зокрема, я б розпочав
свою презентацію з короткого вступу про
себе мені 35, я спочатку українець,
і я заснував компанію в 2016 році з
простою ідеєю, що все
можна змінити, хоча наша початкова
ідея була
фактично розгорнута нещодавно, а зовсім
недавно два  років тому, але я думаю,
що буде дуже цікаво, що ми
насправді
робимо сьогодні, тому ми стикаємося і
працюємо з проблемою
вкрадених транспортних засобів, тому що ми вважаємо, що
приблизно два мільйони автомобілів
були викрадені протягом
останніх років, і менше 15
з них повернуто назад
власникам,
і ми розуміємо, що міста насправді
хочуть боротися з цією проблемою,
встановлюючи багато розумних камер і
камер відеоспостереження на наших вулицях,
але факт є  що це насправді не
працює, і коли ми думаємо про те, чому це
не працює,
це тому, що всі ці камери
зосереджені в основному на розпізнаванні номерів,
тому, коли ви бачите номер, ви можете
знайти автомобіль, якщо
номер прихований або є  після зняття ви не
зможете побачити автомобіль,
по-друге, вам потрібно мати
операторів, щоб вручну розпочати пошук
і фактично
обробити запит, і третій,
оскільки у вас багато зацікавлених сторін, ви
іноді майже знаєте, як
знайти свою камеру  не в ідеальний
спосіб для конкретного агентства,
і тому ми насправді прийшли і
побудували, ми створили AI для
розуміння транспортних засобів за моделями за моделями
за
поколіннями за кольорами, якщо ми бачимо
табличку,
ми також можемо  ідентифікувати лезо, але нас
майже не хвилює
, бачимо ми його чи ні, приблизно
так він виглядає,
тому ми йдемо будь-яким шляхом, ми беремо будь-яке джерело відео,
це може бути смартфон, може бути банкомат,
він може бути хорошої чи поганої якості  камеру, і
ми майже
чудово розуміємо автомобілі з дуже високим
рівнем точності, а
тепер давайте поговоримо про наш маршрут
в рамках європейського фінансування,
ми насправді подали
заявку на горизонт 2020 з 2018 року
ми подавали кілька разів, перший раз, коли
виграли перший етап,
це було 50 000  грант євро, який допоміг
нам фактично, як
ви знаєте, структурно продумати та досягти
певного прогресу в дослідженні
та фактично підготувати заявку
на другий етап, але я маю сказати, що
на другий етап ми подавали заявку так багато
разів, і ми ще не виграли  ми
отримали
багато знаків досконалості, тож якщо ми
зможемо отримати
цей знак досконалості,
скажімо, ми будемо дуже щасливі
це зробити, але насправді в Україні ця
ймовірність дуже обмежена, я маю на увазі, що ми знаємо  ну
про те, що ви насправді можете
бути іноземною компанією, скажімо, у Польщі,
а потім взяти це та подати заявку на
місцевий бренд в Україні,
такої можливості немає, тому якщо ви можете якимось чином
підтримати цих осіб, я думаю, що це
буде
дуже корисно.  ми подали заявку на ці
гранти з цим проектом
із системою мій проект це наш
оригінальний
проект невеликий пристрій, який ви вставляєте в
автомобіль, який сканує широку частину і який
повідомляє вам, чи є якийсь ризик, щоб ви
насправді почувалися комфортніше
під час їзди  мій останній
слайд на сьогодні, і я знаю, що
час обмежений, тому я не буду витрачати більше часу,
я думаю, що трійка кращих забирає для нас,
тому що ми насправді робимо,
як я сказав вам, заявка на грант протягом
останніх двох років,
першим є  попросіть професіонала
за професійною підтримкою,
ми виграли, а потім ми працюємо як
компанія,
і ми фактично з кількома компаніями,
які готують для нас заявки, і
я думаю, що
ось компроміс від однієї компанії  де ви можете
приготувати все самі,
але конкуренція дуже висока,
тому якщо ви хочете збільшити свої шанси,
вам потрібно попросити підтримки,
другий не довіряйте тому, що знає, я
маю на увазі, що ми
багато разів чули відгуки,
що тут щось погане, щось погане
інколи це неоднозначні відгуки,
ми продовжуємо працювати над цим, ми ніколи не говоримо «ні»
і ніколи не слухаємо «ні», і
так, просто продовжуйте працювати над покращенням
вашого додатка, одного дня ви
будете там,
а третій не забувайте про
ваш бізнес насправді,
хоча, оскільки всі ми, дослідники, у певному
сенсі не забуваємо, що вам
потрібно виконувати, і ми побачили, що ви знаєте
команди, які були лише
інноваторами на папері, ми
вважаємо, що ви повинні робити те, що ми
маємо насправді  покажіть ринку, що
вам потрібно
повернути перевірку, а потім ви
повинні включити це у свою
програму
, щоб збільшити свої шанси, ось і
все, дуже дякую, мені приємно
бути з
вами сьогодні.  дякую, алекс, за ваш дійсний
внесок,
ми бажаємо вам успіху у вашому бізнесі,
дякую,
і останній удар і останній
потік належатиме міс Каріні Шакбасян,
голові національного контактного пункту
горизонту 2020,
вона збирається прямі заходи та
навчальні програми  о,
будь ласка, ласкаво просимо, Каріна, ти мене чуєш,
так, я чую, дякую, ти бачиш
мою презентацію так
так, будь ласка,
я прошу вибачення, е, що я пропустив у
розкладі твою презентацію
в цей момент, тому ні, це приємно,
що стосується
цих успішних історій  вони будуть
заохочувати людей до
активнішої участі в Horizon Europe і,
звісно, після цього, після того, як іс
орії успіху повернуться до організаційних пи
ань і н
явних можливостей взяти уч
сть у ре
ультатах Horizon 2020 та Horiz
n Europe на
тупний слайд, будь ласка, наступний сл
йд.  ха ось лише коротко, щоб нагадати
, які
існують акції mariscoloskere
і в усіх них
бере участь Україна бере участь ух
більше  або менш успішно, наприклад,
такі типи, як інноваційні торгові
мережі,
дослідницькі та інноваційні схеми обміну персоналом.
Ці
схеми вони призначені як для досвідчених
дослідників
для науково-дослідних установ, так і для
різних типів дослідницьких співробітників,
індивідуальні стипендії, вони призначені лише для
досвідчених дослідників та для співробітників пост-
документів
-Знайдений співфінанс, це програма для
спільного фінансування регіональних національних та
міжнародних програм, таких як грантові
програми, як-от
стипендії та отримання додаткового
внеску від європейської
комісії,
і, звичайно, п'ятий тип –
вечір європейських дослідників, це підвищення
рівня обізнаності,
публічні заходи, наступний слайд, будь
ласка  якщо ми говоримо про індивідуальні
програми, це, звичайно, головне
, і єдине, скажімо, це
індивідуальні стипендії в акціях
msca наступний слайд, це
надзвичайно конкурентоспроможна програмна акція
, оскільки кожного року, коли
присуджуються Нобелівські премії, ми чуємо, що ці
благородні
призи стипендіатів стипендіатів вони колись
вони раніше були
якось пов'язані з діями msca, або
вони були колегами,
або вони були
координаторами таких проектів,
ці індивідуальні стипендії, вони,
звісно, існуватимуть на горизонті Єв
опи, ал
будуть певні обмеження, накладені, йм
вірно, це буде  буде згадано в
наступній презентації наших європейських
колег,
але все ж це дуже конкурентна, але
дуже популярна схема участі,
і якщо кілька років тому на цей конкурс було подано лише
чотири-шість тисяч
пропозицій, а
зараз останній конкурс їх
було подано
одинадцять  тисячі пропозицій,
головною особливістю цього є мобільність
, а це означає, що ви повинні
бути готові кинути
навчальний заклад, щоб залишити свою країну, щоб
взяти з собою сім’ю та повернутися в
нову країну, наприклад, до європейської країни
та  розвивати там свою дослідницьку кар’єру
,
тому це індивідуальне спілкування – це не
лише дослідницький проект та отримання
результати цього проекту,
але мова йде про
розвиток вашої дослідницької кар'єри
через мобільність, наступний слайд, будь ласка,
ще один, наступний,
так що це розширення стипендії
це як додаткова можливість
для представників країн, що розширюються,
включаючи Україну
, отримати додаткові шанси виграти
індивідуальні стипендії, тому  коли ви
подаєте свою пропозицію щодо індивідуальної
стипендії
в частині а, вам просто потрібно
погодитися з питанням, що ви хочете брати
участь у розширенні стипендії
і таким чином
збільшити ваші шанси на фінансування, тому
ви поставте галочку так,
і це означає, що якщо ви зробили  якщо не виграти
в першому
колі оцінювання, буде просто
другий раунд приєднання
лише серед тих пропозицій, де приймаюча
організація є з
країни, що розширюється,
наприклад, за останні два роки
було профінансовано 72 таких індивідуальних стипендій,
а на цей рік виділено сім мільйонів євро
на
ця схема буде продовжена
і в Хорі  zon europe також наступний
слайд
на веб-порталі Mercury actions ви
можете
знайти багато пропозицій
стипендіатів форм грантів та
відкритих вакансій, які фінансуються
через
msca actions uh через співфонд
і, звичайно, інноваційні торгові
мережі, тому тут ви можете знайти  що
таких відкритих пропозицій є 186,
наступний слайд,
це приклад того, як виглядають ці пропозиції,
наприклад, 15 дослідників на ранній стадії
шукали, тому це означає, що
вони хочуть отримати грант на інноваційну
мережу, і вони шукають
докторську дисертацію  студенти наступний
слайд також існує величезний портал
для всіх дослідницьких організацій у
європейському союзі,
це ваш портал доступу, і ось
величезна база всіх
відкритих вакансій та пропозицій роботи у
сфері досліджень та інновацій в
Європейському Союзі,
яку ви можете туди помістити  своє резюме, або ви можете
найняти персонал через цей портал, або
ви можете
шукати там пропозиції про роботу на наступному слайді,
щоб це залежало від того, який пошук ви збираєтеся
робити  r наприклад, ви шукаєте
можливості фінансування та наступний слайд,
і тут ви просто отримуєте цей
результат, ну, ви
переглядаєте, наприклад, пропозиції роботи, які
фінансуються через європейську дослідницьку
програму, це означає, що ви
побачите результати грантів та можливостей для стипендій,
тож тут ви можете  подивіться це, що
існує зараз на веб-сторінці
часткового доступу за рік, загалом є 7
000 відкритих
пропозицій щодо роботи, а якщо говорити про
реакцію медичної допомоги,
то є навіть пропозиції від
проектів fp7, і, звичайно, є
пропозиції щодо співфінансування та  uh
innovative networks madison security
actions uh
відкриті вакансії для окремих
дослідників
о, наступний слайд, будь ласка, о, і тут я просто
хочу нагадати вам,
що ще є відкритий дзвінок, ви можете
мати останній шанс взяти участь у
акції Horizon 2020 msca закликайте це
вечір європейських дослідників
і  він відкритий до 12 січня, тож я
сподіваюся, що ви вже
підготували свою пропозицію, якщо
подали
попередні пропозиції до  попередні роки,
будь ласка, ви можете повторно надіслати
його зараз із деякими покращеннями,
тому бюджет становить 8 мільйонів євро, тому це
означає, що буде досить багато,
досить велика кількість пропозицій,
поданих на
наступному слайді, будь ласка,
наступний слайд, ви можете пропустити їх
так, будь ласка, о  наступний слайд також, оскільки
цього
не вистачає часу, тому різні типи
організацій підтримуються через
ніч дослідників і підтримуються різні типи
дій,
головна мета – підвищити обізнаність громадськості
про позитивну роль
науки дослідника, щоб пояснити, що
роблять дослідники та головну мету  це
зацікавити молодь, зацікавити
дітей,
щоб, можливо, в майбутньому обрати
професію, пов’язану з
наукою та дослідниками, наступний слайд,
будь ласка,
і ось просто, щоб нагадати вам деякі
статистичні дані,
що 73
це не проекти, а 73
організації-учасники вже
виграли uh purple one um  проекти msca,
на жаль, якщо ми говоримо про
індивідуальні стипендії, то є лише один
індивідуальний стипендіат  p
uh пов'язано з україною, і це
вхідна стипендія, це був стипендіат
із Великобританії, який прибув до
київсько-махільської академії для дослідників,
але ми бачимо, що все ще ми
найбільш
активні в рисовій схемі,
який наступний слайд, будь ласка, це означає, що
ми дійсно маємо
змінити ці результати до наступного горизонту
європа
, наскільки ми бачимо, що кількість
українських дослідників зменшилася в
порівнянні з fp7,
також зменшилася кількість або
значно зменшилася кількість
дослідників, які йдуть в українську
організацію,
це означає, що,
звісно, є деякі  об'єктивно е-е-е-е
для цього е-е-е-е-у-у моменти, як-от
війна йде на українській території, як-
от відсутність
фінансування української науки, і це означає, що е-
м-м-м, можливо, якісь проблеми з дослідницькою
інфраструктурою тощо,
але все-таки цю ситуацію можна покращити
до наступного горизонту
Європи  запрограмувати
цей момент я маю повернути слово
до крісла, натиснувши
на четверту сесію,
так скільки слайдів у вас є
це оооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооооtiє,
будь ласка,
о так і позитивне те,
що фінансування українських організацій
зросло вдвічі, тепер це остаточні 11
з половиною мільйонів бюджету ЄС виділено
українським організаціям, і
це не остаточне  результати курсу
та останній слайд, будь ласка,
гм ні інший
так, будь ласка, якщо ми ви знаєте так, якщо ми
говоримо про
практику так, дякую участь
у різних типах організацій це майже
50 50 56 брати участь у академіці
та неакадемічні
інститути приватні при
та мікс вони  активна участь
в акціях msc
ефективний 43 відсотки і
кількість внеску вашого
європейського союзу в українські
організації
є найбільшими сумами, які надходять
приватним компаніям до MSC, а
на другому місці вчений,
тому дозвольте мені сказати  що в україні є
чотири дії ncp
ncps msc і, будь ласка,
якщо ви збираєтеся подати свої пропозиції,
будь ласка, спершу зверніться
за вас  і ми можемо дати вам
необхідну пораду дякую дуже дякую
каріна
ух дуже цікава розмова та
інформативна для учасників я бажаю
людям
успішної участі в програмі Марії Кюрі
і тепер я маю
повернути слово голові
можливостей для українських
дослідників  і новаторів,
мабуть, до Брюсселя, я думаю,
будь ласка, ласкаво просимо дуже дякую
Анатолій, дійсно, ласкаво просимо з
Брюсселя
гм, я Мотт Фішер, я з
європейської комісії з Директорату
з досліджень та інновацій,
і мені справді приємно
поділитися
ця сесія назвала можливості для
українських дослідників
та інноваторів, м-м, я
вважаю дуже цікавим те,
що ЄС
є частиною цієї сесії, я думаю, що це
чітко демонструє, що
rni дійсно одна з найуспішніших
корпорацій, які
ми мали між ЄС та україною  і
ми дійсно хочемо, щоб це продовжувалося
, буде чотири презентації, які
розглядатимуть різні можливості  Я
лежав там для українських дослідників
на сесії, перш ніж
дати слово нашому першому доповідачу, я просто хочу
підтвердити сьогоднішній аудиторії,
що насправді Україна має те, що ми
називаємо
статусом асоціації до 2020 року,
і що Україна висловила  його зацікавленість
пов’язати з горизонтом Європи та
уратом майбутньою програмою урату,
ми працюємо з міністерством,
щоб це як прикро
асоціація відбулося якомога швидше,
беручи до уваги, що регламент,
який встановлює горизонт європи, ще не діє,
тому ми  не можу розпочати жодних
офіційних переговорів,
але я можу запевнити вас, присутні тут
сьогодні, що обидві сторони готуються
до того, щоб це відбулося
якомога швидше, тому, будь ласка,
слідкуйте за оновленнями сьогоднішньої дискусії,
тому що можливості, які
нададуть мої колеги
, відкриті чи будуть  будьте відкритими для українських
дослідників,
якщо у вас є запитання до
доповідачів, будь ласка, використовуйте вікно чату,
я спробую переконатися, що я  стежте за
цим
без подальших зволікань, тоді дозвольте мені
звернутися до
мого колеги Клемента Євро, який розпочне
цю дискусію про те, як надихнути нас
на майбутнє, тому
Клемент Пол твій,
я дуже радий бути з вами, це
вранці у
мене був я з комісії
я другий національний експерт з
Франції,
і я хотів би сказати, що я мав
нагоду зустрітися з вашим
національним контактним центром з правових та
фінансових
питань пару років тому в Парижі,
а сьогодні на  Після угоди
між главою держави ЄС щодо наступної
багаторічної фінансової рамкової
програми для Європейського Союзу я
радий представити вам
горизонт Європи та обговорити з вами
наші найкращі українські дослідники
та бізнес, які зможуть
скористайтеся цією програмою,
тому сьогодні вранці я
хотів би представити
вам причини, чому Європейський Союз
вирішив піти на підйом у Європі,
а потім ми побачимо, як програма
структурована і як ви
зможете брати участь,
дякую, ми можемо перейти до наступного
слайда наступний, вибачте, знову
ідеальний, тому це буде нашим
наріжним каменем, оскільки ви знаєте, що
в 2015 році Об’єднані нації
дійсно вирішили домовитися
про новий набір  цілей, так званих
цілей сталого розвитку, є
колеги, і дослідницькі
інновації відіграють у цьому важливу роль,
справді, це визнано у
публікаціях Організації Об'єднаних Націй,
пов'язаних
з цими цілями сталого розвитку,
як один із чотирьох
основних рівнів для  мати можливість
трансформувати
наші економіки та суспільства
до більш зеленого справедливого та цифрового
майбутнього, тому перша ідея, яку потрібно взяти до
уваги,
горизонт європи підтримає
нашу трансформацію в усіх
соціально-економічних секторах нашої економіки,
ми підемо до цього за пару  хвилин на
наступному слайді, будь ласка,
ось, а не причина, яка була
дуже важливою для ух під час
підготовки горизонту європи,
пов'язана т  o той факт, що, хоча Європа
є головною
науковою виробничою
сферою світу, нам ще
потрібно зробити додаткову роботу
для того, щоб наші знання поширювалися
в наших економіках і суспільствах,
тому горизонт європи не лише
покликаний надати рішення щодо
сталого майбутнього,
але  також має на меті зробити це
шляхом зростання добробуту
та можливостей для всіх,
ми можемо перейти до наступного слайда, який
помістить тут невелике нагадування про
те, що в наших договорах Європейського союзу
говориться про
дослідницьку політику, що є спільною компетенцією
між ЄС
та його членом  держава, і вона має три
основні
цілі, по-перше,
зміцнити європейську науково-
технічну базу,
тому мова йде про підтримку
творчості наших кращих
дослідників, друга
мета – підвищити конкурентоспроможність європейського інноваційного
потенціалу
та зайнятість, тож мова йде про процвітання, як я
згадував кілька секунд тому  і останнє, але
не в останню чергу,
європейська політика в галузі дослідницьких інновацій
також має на
меті досягти  Я
хотів би
подякувати всім вам, тому що я
сказав, що під час нашого спільного проектування
горизонту.  Європа розпочато у 2019 році
та закінчено у 2020 році
українські дослідницькі інноваційні
суб’єкти зробили внесок і були
залучені до наших різних заходів,
таких як дні дослідницьких інновацій у
2019 та 20 роках.
Велике спасибі за це, а тепер ми
перейдемо до наступного слайду та  почніть
представляти архітектуру
програми,
і насправді ми можемо перейти до
[Музика]
не тільки до наступного слайду, але й до наступного слайду
з
трьома основними стовпами горизонту Європи,
тому поки
слайд завантажується, тому що я не бачу його
на своєму  екран
Я б почав з того, що horizon
europe був розроблений для
забезпечення плавної еволюції з горизонтом
20,
тому архітектура програми
базується на трьох основних стовпах,
а додаткова частина – перша
– відображає те, що говориться в договорі про
розвиток наукової та
технологічної
основи за допомогою інвестицій в дослідницькі інновації,
тому тут
ви знову знайдете можливості для
творчої діяльності,
це те, що європейські дослідження
ради про, але ви
також матимете доступ до
навчальних програм для дослідників
через розрахунки Маліка Ладо,
які були створені з
20 століття, тепер я б сказав, що
останнє, але не в останню чергу,
гм, і Pilar one horizon europe з
нами також буде
підтримувати інвестиції
в дослідницьку та інноваційну
інфраструктуру, основне наукове
обладнання
, а також гарантувати, що Європа все
ще залишається
найкращим і найсучаснішим
обладнанням, це також забезпечить
рішення
для кожного дослідника, який належить до
європейського
дослідницького простору, щоб мати доступ до цих
інструментів, щоб він був  також я б сказав, що це
майже можливість знизу вгору
перейти до pilar також, тому pilatu полягає в тому, щоб
використовувати наші
інвестиції
в дослідницькі інновації для досягнення загальної
мети досліджень Європейського Союзу в рамках політики Європейського Союзу за допомогою кластерів, які
відображають основні
соціально-економічні сектори наших
економік,
ми переконаємося, що завдяки дослідницьким
інноваціям
ми  буде в змозі запропонувати
конкретне інноваційне рішення для сонячної енергії
,
щоб забезпечити перехід між
цифровими, з одного боку, і зеленими, з
іншого боку, що означає відсутність
клімату та
біорізноманіття щодо того, щоб
наша здатність створювати найкращі
знання поширювалася належним чином
по всій нашій економіці, але
Європейська
рада з інновацій, яка є основним
інструментом у рамках цього рівня, безкоштовна
, а також конкретна підтримує
підприємців, щоб вони
мали можливість розвивати свій
інноваційний
бізнес, тому з цим рівнем, вільним
знову,
ми прагнемо отримати переваги
науково-технологічних
інвестицій i  Щоб створити
процвітання, ми
побачимо останню частину, яка стосується
розширення
та зміцнення європейського дослідницького
простору,
і тут ідея полягає в тому, щоб
краще з’єднати наші наукові
спільноти
по всій Європі
зараз, коли ми говорили
про головну архітектуру, яку
я б запропонував  ви дуже стисле
порівняння між горизонтом Європи
та горизонтом 20 лише для того, щоб
проілюструвати, що ми могли
покращити в порівнянні з нашою наступною
рамковою програмою, тому наступний слайд, будь ласка,
щоб це було  п’ять основних сфер, де
ми можемо говорити про
відповідну модифікацію [Музика], я дам сигнал
, що я
залишу своїх колег
розвивати місії та партнерства,
тому я почну з Європейської
ради з інновацій, але оскільки ми
вже говорили про це, я
пропоную, щоб  ми переходимо безпосередньо до слайда
про міжнародне співробітництво,
і міжнародна співпраця
має різні виміри
від дослідження  перспективи інноваційних інвестицій
та враховуючи
актуальність зеленого та цифрового
переходу,
ідея полягає в тому, щоб переконатися, що горизонт
Європи має можливість
створювати суспільні блага,
а знання є одним із основних
відповідних суспільних благ,
які можна кваліфікувати як такі,
але  на додаток до цього через
інвестиції в технології для
забезпечення стратегічної автономії Європи
горизонт європи також надасть
можливість нашим міжнародним партнерам та
асоційованим
країнам також отримати вигоду
від цієї автономної стратегії для
себе,
тому знову ж таки головною ідеєю нашого
міжнародного співробітництва
є  боротися з нашими глобальними викликами
та надавати рішення для всіх наших
партнерів,
щоб також отримати вигоду від
їхньої стратегічної
автономії, можливо, особлива
згадка про той факт, що
міжнародне співробітництво у сфері асоціації в горизонті
Європи
відіграє дуже важливу роль для того, щоб
щоб Європа була в змозі спільно
проектувати та співпрацювати  Лізуйте свою
політику в галузі досліджень та інновацій
зі своїми сусідами, велике спасибі,
зараз я перейду до питання, пов'язаного з
відкритою наукою,
відкрита наука є дуже актуальною, тому
що це спосіб, яким горизонт європи працює разом
або з
відкритим науковим горизонтом європи або через нього, відкритий науковий горизонт європи
також принесе користь
будь-який
дослідник або будь-який бізнес, який не
пов’язаний із своєю діяльністю, відкрита наука
робить обов’язковим вільний доступ до всіх
наукових публікацій
, які створюються завдяки нашій
діяльності,
це означає, що це знову ж таки
приносить користь кожному, незалежно від
їх фактичної участі чи ні від
діяльності,
тоді я б  перейти до наступного слайда щодо
розширення,
але тут я, можливо, просто
згадаю, що в порівнянні з горизонтом
2020 року
нові європейські території
були включені, вибачте,
до розширення прийнятних
територій, і я говорю
про заморську територію
наших держав-членів з центром  в
іспанії, португалії та франції,
я б зараз перейшов на
конкретний календар до дати
слово Невілу та
Марії, щоб повідомити, що тепер, коли ми маємо угоду
про багаторічну фінансову структуру
на 21
27 рік, ми зможемо завершити
нашу підготовку горизонту Європи і,
дуже
ймовірно, ми десь опублікуємо наші перші робочі
програми
21 квітня
ці програми
відображатимуть архітектуру, яку ми представили
пару
хвилин тому, і
незалежно від просування
переговорів про асоціацію
між Європейським Союзом
та Україною та для Horizon Europe
ви в будь-якому випадку знайдете теми, які
спонукатимуть до участі  треті
країни
знову, незалежно від статусу в
асоціації, тож я б сказав, і це
хороша новина,
що ви вже
можете подивитися на наше обговорення,
щоб розпочати свою підготовку,
це все на моєму боці.
цей огляд,
я думаю, деякі слайди
були трохи заморожені,
тому, можливо, якщо це можливо, ми
попросимо організаторів  розмістіть посилання,
можливо, на презентацію Horizon
Europe
на веб-сайті, якщо це добре, щоб
кожен мав доступ до цього,
я не можу підкреслити важливість того,
що сказав
клімат у важливості орієнтації та
підтримки зеленого та цифрового
переходу
зараз  для всіх вас, хто хоче взяти
участь у
Horizon Europe, будь ласка, майте це на увазі, тому що це буде помітно у всіх дзвінках, які надходять, якщо є якісь, я не бачив жодних запитань у чаті для Клемонта,
гм, якщо  це все ще так,
я не бачив жодного, звичайно,
ви знаєте, не соромтеся використовувати чат
під час обговорення, і ми також спробуємо
відповісти на
запитання, гм,
але я думаю, що зараз я хотів би перейти до нашого
наступного  спікер,
який також збирається висвітлити одну з
новинок Horizon Europe, яку Клермонт щойно
торкнувся,
є експериментальним блоком,
який насправді черпає наше
натхнення, я думаю, тому я бачу, що
бачу презентацію
Я думав, що
зараз почнуться місії, я
думаю, що це
презентація про місії, яка
черпає натхнення з місії Аполлон-
11 1969 року. Тож
я збираюся попросити свого колегу Невіла
Гм  просто відвези нас на місяць
так, привіт, у мене дуже
коротка хм, ну, це виглядає краще, хм, у мене дуже коротка презентація, яку я міг би завантажити
сам, якщо ви дозволите мені,
гм, дайте мені побачити, чи це працює,
гм, ви бачите, що так,
ми бачимо  це так, у слайд-шоу це буде
трохи простіше, я зроблю це, звичайно,
так
чудово, дуже дякую, тому
ситуація з нашими
місіями, гм, я думаю, що у мене є 10
хвилин,
так, будь ласка, місії - це
просто спосіб вирішення дуже
інтегрована
мода, основні суспільні проблеми, як ви
сказали
більше, натхненням є такі
великі проекти, як Apollo Moonshot,
і вся суть в тому, як
ми можемо
об’єднати цілий ряд різних
інструментів, які фінансують
політику потоків  Щоб вирішити
щось скоординовано з
чітким розумінням того, що це за призначення
та часові рамки, коли вони вирушили на
Місяць, ми
поставили собі за мету відправити людину
на Місяць до кінця десятиліття та
привезти  Він безпечно додому
, у певному сенсі, це простий спосіб
описати,
як ви повинні створити місію, ми
тісно співпрацювали з командами експертів
протягом останнього року. Рада
місій на чолі з кількома високопоставленими
особами Паскалем Ламі Конні Хедегардом,
колишня європейська комісія.
комісарів і їхня робота полягала в тому, щоб
спробувати
визначити предметні області для цих
місій, самі місії, які
ми розпочали з нашого списку, який був
на горизонті європейський законопроект,
а простіше кажучи, ці області
– це рак, зміна клімату, океан,
сезон, води,
ех розумні  міста кліматично нейтральні розумні
міста ґрунт здоров'я та їжа
ми досягли точки наприкінці
вересня,
коли ради місії завершили
свою роботу та доставили її до  комісія
під час заходу European ri days
це був церемоніальний момент, але,
тим не менш,
отримав величезний розголос
з тих пір, що сталося, так це те, що
п'ять місій були
політично
підтверджені комісією в документі, який
лежить в основі встановлення пріоритетів для
горизонту
Європи  і це стратегічний план
зараз, я думаю, що я хотів би сказати, що
є неймовірно важливим, це те, що місії -
це не
просто дослідження та інновації, звичайно,
вони виходять з дослідницьких інновацій,
вони є в нашому
законопроекті для горизонту Європи, вони
є  Новинка для Horizon
Europe, але насправді успіх
місій буде залежати від того, наскільки добре
ми об’єднаємо
цілу низку різних політик щодо потоків фінансування,
як я сказав на початку, ви можете бачити,
наприклад, у містах це не просто
пошук нових технологій.  рішення
, про які йдеться, наприклад, про розгортання тих
, про використання підходів, які
вже доступні,
звичайно, ні  t лише про
одну область досліджень та інновацій, яку ви
можете зрозуміти, ви знаєте
кращий спосіб життя, краще здоров’я, кращі
засоби транспорту,
це все приклади лише у
випадку міст, де у вас дійсно є цілий
ряд різних елементів, які можуть
мати місце, щоб
забезпечити такий результат  цілі, які ми маємо, тож це ті
назви, які були політично підтверджені
комісією наприкінці жовтня
, це робочі назви, і зараз ми
переходимо на підготовчу фазу,
яка дозволяє нам детально розробити
плани виконання для кожної
місії
та  плани впровадження, звісно,
инні розглядати логіку втручання, ці
і, ін
естиції, необхідні показники дл
вимірювання ефективності, усі ці ре
і, і ц
дійсно важливий крок, який на
потрібно пройти, і, звичайно, ті,
що в ц
х планах впровадження мають  також
чітко уявіть цілий ряд інших внесків
за межі досліджень та інновацій,
і ви це бачите  n цей перший слайд-
список місій um,
які розробляються
на підготовчому етапі,
і пункт про 12-місячний
підготовчий
період зараз, оскільки це перша
робоча програма Horizon Europe, це буде
um під час її запуску для місій, і ми
ми вже чули від
Клермона хвилину тому, ми
шукаємо приблизно в квітні
для цієї першої робочої програми, місії
в цій першій робочій програмі під час її запуску
будуть
досить легковажно представлені,
буде окрема частина робочої програми
для кожного для  місії і кожна
з самих
місій матиме певний підрозділ, але
на даний
момент у цій робочій програмі ми маємо лише п’ять мільйонів на місію, тому
що вся ідея, звичайно, полягає в тому, що ми ще не
запускаємо, ми розробляємо.
місії на цьому підготовчому
етапі,
так що типи речей, які ви
побачите там
, пов’язані з підготовкою до місій,
встановлення платформи для місій
, коли ми
приходьте, щоб запустити
повномасштабний, ми справді там, ви знаєте, що
можете швидко
прискорюватися, дуже швидко розширюватися, справді,
ви можете запитати, який загальний бюджет для
місій добре, ми маємо вказівки в горизонті
Європи,
я маю на увазі більше, ніж вказівки про те, що це
передбачено в горизонті  Європа,
що до 10 частин бюджету
кластера
рівня 2 мкм буде взято на
місію, тому якщо ми візьмемо
10 частин кластерів для місій,
то маємо дуже значну
суму, справді, зараз не зрозуміло, чи потрібні нам
усі  що і чи буде це 10
з кожного з кластерів, тому що
ви можете зрозуміти, що потреби ri для
кожної місії різні,
і тому ми хочемо пройти
процес детального планування, де ми починаємо
з цієї
загальної суми, але потім дивимося  у кожному
конкретному випадку те, що нам насправді
потрібно, і щоб суми, які надходять від
кожного з
кластерів, могли відрізнятися,
я думаю, що я вже згадував цей
пункт щодо плану впровадження,
консультації, які  буде
вкрай важливою протягом всієї фази паритету
і
яка була настільки важливою
до цього,
продовжиться через комітет стратегічної тіньової програми
та його підгрупи, і тепер буде
дуже тісний
діалог, який стане останнім кроком,
і важливо бути чітким
це те, що все ще буде
оцінка підготовчого етапу
планів впровадження, які
висуваються, у мене немає підстав думати, що ми
не можемо бути переконливими, але це ще
одна
перешкода, яку ми повинні подолати, тому ми
якщо розглядати цей підготовчий період
до 12 місяців, це не
обов’язково для всіх місій,
деякі можуть пройти швидше, ніж це залежить
від того,
чи вони будуть готові, але в кінці
цього періоду для кожної місії буде
оцінка  просто задати питання,
чи все у нас на місці, чи ми
довіряємо,
це суміш критеріїв для
місій, які вже викладені в
законодавстві для горизонту
Європи, але також  Іншими
словами,
можливо, це недобре, ми хочемо бути амбітними, але, з
іншого боку, ми також хочемо бути реалістами,
і це був ключовий момент щодо всього
законодавства
та принципів, які
створені для місій, тому ось історія
у нас є п'ять місій, які переходять до
підготовчого етапу, у
нас є робоча програма, яка містить від
п'яти мільйонів
до п'яти мільйонів на кожну місію, яку потрібно
розробити,
готуємось до місій, а потім
ми маємо повний запуск місій,
який відбудеться
в кінці  цього підготовчого періоду,
і це
надійде через оновлення робочої програми Horizon Europe,
але я повинен підкреслити, що я просто сказав
на початку і знову сказав, що місії – це
не лише дослідження
інновацій, ми очікуємо побачити ряд
інших внесків від  через
бюджет європейського союзу
багаторічну фінансову
структуру, але ми також сподіваємося на створення
портфелів, які інтегрують
внески з національного рівня
регіонального рівня.  діяльність,
тому дуже дякую, я сподіваюся, що я затримався
на часі, це історія,
дуже дякую, і я думаю,
що
ви прилипли до часу, тому
я справді думаю, що з
вашої презентації випливає ця потреба виглядати
на
міждисциплінарне право, це те, що ми
всі повинні мати на увазі,
і всім дослідникам,
новаторам, які сьогодні сидять у кімнаті,
будь ласка, дайте це, ви знаєте, ми зараз
розглядаємо, як це зробити по-іншому
та як підключити та  як вийти за межі
досліджень, і
я дуже дякую за це,
я дивився на чат, я не
бачу жодних запитань,
будь ласка, скористайтеся нагодою, щоб поставити будь-який
гарячий запит
до Невіла, тепер я не бачив жодних піднятих
рук,
тому iii  не знаю, чи була моя
адреса в програмі, її не було в тій, яку
я вказав, можливо, ви могли б
розповсюдити моє ім'я, гм,
мою адресу електронної пошти пізніше, на
випадок, якщо хтось захоче надіслати
додаткові запитання  що
ми
обов'язково зробимо  Я зроблю це, дуже дякую,
Невілл за те, що ви надали цю можливість, це д-р Агілера з україни, я
хотів би запитати ведучого,
я пам'ятаю, під час деяких президентських
подій
комісія
запропонувала вилучити технології,
а не просувати їх,
це стосується безпосередньо  наші
дослідження та інноваційний процес, щоб
прискорити комерціалізацію,
щоб вони витягували найбільш
перспективні продукти з
проекту, було запропоновано,
про що
зараз у цьому курсі
я не впевнений, що я повністю
зрозумів питання,
дозвольте мені спробувати відповісти і  якщо це
працює для вас, то добре, я думаю,
що ви говорите не тільки
про
нові технології, RNI, які
знадобляться для місій
, це, безумовно, так, я
думаю,
ви можете побачити в кількох випадках кілька з
них  місії дійсно можна стверджувати,
що
вже існує багато рішень,
потенційних рішень, потенційних
технологій
або наявних технологій  і
насправді те, що нам потрібно зробити,
– це перевести їх
у ситуації, коли вони можуть змінити
ситуацію, тож,
наприклад, можна сказати, що
значні зусилля в
кількох із цих місій будуть спрямовані на те, щоб
демонстранти широкомасштабні демонстранти
пілотували діяльність з розгортання, а не
лише  винаходити нові речі,
я не знаю, чи це була
саме та відповідь, яку ви шукали,
добре, дякую за відповідь,
я думаю переважно про прискорення
появи продукту в будь-якому проекті,
пов’язаному з інноваціями,
тому цей стимул
у попередньому горизонті 2020 року
штовхав лише на
прискорення  процес з
інвестиціями
безпосередньо з програми безпосередньо з
програми моя пропозиція,
але цього
недостатньо скоротити період
комерціалізації
і перед тим,
як люди та посадові особи комісії
запропонували
інший механізм прискорення
процесу комерціалізації,
щоб безпосередньо знайти
перспективні продукти  в
проекті
заздалегідь перед проектом  ect закінчив
і спробував також стимулювати фінансуванням
появу нового продукту з цього
найбільш перспективного проекту
, що я мав на увазі одне запитання до
вас, дуже дякую добре, дякую,
якщо я можу відповісти на це справді, так що
це  інструменти, на які ви посилаєтеся, м-м-
м, справді, щоб
прискорити дослідження, м-м-м, справді
, я думаю, що клімат, м
-м-м, місії не мають
цієї мети.
щоб вийти на ринок, вони
набагато ширші в
цьому інструменті, про який ви маєте на
увазі, це той клімат,
який представив, це Європейська
інноваційна
рада, це чия робота буде саме такою,
щоб спробувати переконатися,
що яскраві ідеї та  Яскраві
технології фактично повністю
розширені та представлені на ринку,
це ми мали пілотний проект цього е-е-е в
рамках 2020 року, і ідея полягає в тому, щоб
використати його на повний потенціал у європейському
горизонті,
і, звичайно, якщо  це
цікавить українську дослідницьку спільноту,
я впевнений, що ми можемо
запропонувати міністерству включити в будь-який
майбутній національний день науки
в Україні, і комісія,
звичайно, буде рада  представити
інструмент після запуску
дякую,
дякую, тоді настрій я думаю, гм, я кажу
до побачення, і я дуже щасливий, що був
тут,
гм, будь ласка, надішліть мої контактні дані та
радий
розглянути будь-які подальші дії, дуже дякую
Невілла за це, і
я впевнений, що люди обов'язково продовжать
це,
хм,
якщо ми тепер перейдемо
від місяця і цих дуже амбітних
амбітних цілей, м, і ми зосередимося зараз трохи
більше на
іншому, це не так новинка.
але це очевидна важлива частина
горизонту Європи,
ну, а це партнерство,
я маю сказати, що це інструмент, який
дуже дорогий моєму серцю,
оскільки я тісно працював із чистим небом,
яке є
авіаційним партнерством у попередньому житті.
я більшість з вас у